right now
joe biden is getting slammed by cnn he's
getting slammed by the left and the
right over his handling of
an escalating border crisis they're
saying that encounters have now
surpassed over 100
000 he's reopened some of these
facilities for detaining children that
even donald trump clothes
so he's getting flack from the
progressives he's getting flack from the
conservatives he's not doing enough
he's getting flack from many people on
these border states so we're going to
get into this we're going to talk about
a bit of what's going on
with the the culture and a bit of the
cultural crisis we have here in the u.s
where
the hyperpolarization is resulting in
talk of things like secession
and it seems like joe biden when it
comes to the coveted response when it
comes to his leadership
he's not actually speaking to red states
he's only really speaking about blue
states leaving many
conservatives republicans kind of upset
with the job he's doing but this was
i'd imagine predictable
hyperpolarization has has been expanding
in this country for quite some time it's
been getting worse
it was particularly bad under donald
trump and i think we can be very
critical of the media for a lot of this
and now it's probably only going to get
worse because it seems joe biden simply
got elected
just because a lot of people didn't like
trump we now have a poll coming out that
suggests less than half of voters think
joe biden is capable
of even handling the job of president so
we'll have a good discussion about it
and we have a really great guest tonight
we're being joined by
ellen west i just let you describe
yourself you introduce yourself however
you'd like well it's good to be here
with each and every one of you ian
tim and lydia you know former
retired army lieutenant colonel former
member united states house of
representatives as a matter of fact it
was 10 years ago
that i was serving up here in the house
of representatives and now also the
chairman of the republican party of
texas so it's a pleasure to be here with
each and every one of you
and i i kind of get this feeling like
this is logan's run
and i'm peter houston off and i'm being
brought back into the city with all the
young people
i mean this is this is kind of cool well
i'm 35.
well i got you about 25 years but i'm
still i'm still dead in logan's run
universe yeah you're dead but but you're
a runner right
so you came out and you found me in
sanctuary and you brought me back to the
city
what's the premise i never saw it oh my
god when you turn around
they have a light in their hand that
yeah like when they when they turn 30
they get killed oh geez
so like but they tell them you're being
renewed but you're not being renewed
you're being killed
yeah yeah so they bring people back
everyone there was there was one
person that was the oldest person and
there was this place called sanctuary
and that's where the runners went to so
that they can live a full life
and they found this person out in
sanctuary and they brought him back to
show
to the people that you can't grow old so
it's kind of interesting being here you
know with my salt and pepper flat top
i think you're you're still pretty uh
significant in the political landscape
you're chairman of the texas republican
party
yeah recently you made a you made you
had a quote and also the media was an
uproar saying you were calling for a
secession of texas from the united
states
but you you made a really good point you
like kind of had this like wink moment
of the press where you kind of baited
them into it well absolutely that's one
of the things that the military teaches
you
is that you always think about before
you do anything before you take an
action you you
you know think how would your opposition
you know look at this how would they
respond to and react to it so
basically what i said is that you know
here in the united states of america
there should be a union of
constitutional law-abiding states that
form together
and now of course the left went crazy
about that but if you look at the
preamble of the constitution what does
it say
we the people of the united states
america in order to form a more perfect
union
first thing establish justice so if
you're going to you know get into an
argument
with me about constitutional law-abiding
con
states coming together abiding by the
rule of law
then you're going to lose that argument
they're basically saying they're the
ones who aren't abiding by the rules
absolutely yeah and so and so yesterday
i don't know if you can pull it up but
every monday i put out what is called a
chairman's monday message
and it goes out and so yesterday the
title was constitutionalist
versus secessionist because really the
people that are succeeding in the united
states of america are the people that
are breaking away from the constitution
you look at the legislation that they're
passing h.r 1 which is trying to
nationalize federal elections
show me where in the constitution that
the federal government has the
enumerated power to
run elections that's the state's right
that's the state's responsibility we're
gonna get into all let's
get into all this we'll just you know
keep this as a shorter introduction yeah
introduction but i think it's
interesting considering
you're in texas your borders your border
state yeah you've got serious issues
with the migrant crisis
that you know legal immigrant crisis
absolutely illegal immigrant crisis
um biden's being heavily criticized for
his inability to handle it
and i mean you're also you know
everything we just talked about with the
constitution and the states and the
hyperpolarization so
it's going to be interesting we got ian
hanging out what's up everybody ian
crossland in the house
see ian was trying to interview him you
know yeah
and i'm like i want to know about the
military background your time in
congress what does the chairman of the
republican party do
yeah uh we got lydia pressing all these
yeah
trying to sneak more interviews in with
our guests before they get on that's
miss producer that's
correct you know mark levin has mr
producer you got miss producer
that's right thank you i value that i
like that title
now before we get started with this very
serious conversation or maybe not so
serious conversation head over to
timcast.com
and become a member to get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast
yesterday there were a lot of people who
weren't a big they weren't big fans of
rucka
but we did do an ext an exclusive
segment where we went through
the collapse of the anti-sjw youtubers
or this community
a lot of these people for some reason
either lost their principles
stopped producing content changed and no
longer engage in politics and we get
into why that might be
and it's kind of a nostalgic look at the
earlier years of the culture war
everything's become so serious now it's
very academic
so we decided to have a conversation
about it you should definitely check it
out but we also got other people we've
got cassandra
fairbanks we got ben stewart scott
pressler a bunch of really awesome
exclusive segments so definitely go to
timcast.com
become a member because it really does
help support the show and
in the event we get banned that's where
we will be but
uh and also don't forget to like share
subscribe
hit the notification bell let's read
this first story and i'll just highlight
a couple little snippets and then we'll
just dive into this conversation
cnn of all outlets right now surprising
they report
southwest border crisis leaves biden
vulnerable on
all sides they say the white house may
be loath to call the situation on the
southwestern border
which hundreds of migrant children are
crossing alone a crisis
but it's fast becoming a political
emergency for the president
we have fox news reporting that
encounters have topped 100 000
in just february as the migrant crisis
is spiraling
so here it comes and uh you know so so
alan you're
in texas yeah you're the chairman of the
republican party i mean this is an issue
that's
very seriously affecting you it's
incredibly affecting us and one of the
things you have to understand is that
texas is the number one state in the
united states of america
for human and sex trafficking dallas and
houston are the top two cities
so that's an important part when you
start to have all of these
unaccompanied minors that are being
brought in what happens to them when
they're just released
into the society as a matter of fact
they're looking at bringing three
thousand
of these illegal immigrants uh into
dallas to put them at the k
bayley hutchison convention center then
where do they go from there these are
miners these are miners
and so when you understand that
atmosphere when you understand the
illegality of drugs to the cross and the
drug cartels
and how they're getting richer it comes
back to a very simple premise
why do you break something that is
working if it ain't broke don't fix it
and so you had an immigration situation
that the uh
the bite administration took over it was
fine no one's talking about it
everything is okay but
because you are so owing to the
progressive socialists left and
they have this open borders agenda then
you make the faux pas of going in
and creating a catastrophic situation by
executive order
and now you don't have a means by which
you're going to take care of it and the
important thing that
the the bind administration needs to
understand right now
there's no orange man bad yeah there's
no donald trump boogeyman
out there for people to to to look at
and have that distraction
now all they're doing is saying we got
an issue we got a crisis and no
gen psyche you can't circle back to it
you can't say that this is just a
challenge
this is affecting people black white
hispanic republican democrat independent
libertarian whatever you want to call it
because you are destabilizing one of the
largest states in the united states of
america
well something interesting you just
mentioned it was working right
yeah the system was working well pelosi
says the biden administration inherited
quote a broken system at the border this
is from the hill on march 14th
so they're already deflecting and i
think you know i've covered the
the the migrant crisis throughout the
past several years extensively
the the number of encounters and migrant
children had dropped dramatically
incredibly so under under donald trump
yeah i mean what we're talking about in
the entire last year
is what we've already seen in the last
six weeks
and so this is a crisis situation and
and
you know again they can try this
deflection but the hypocrisy
becomes absolutely laughable if it
weren't so serious it's kind of like you
know the cuomo
kavanaugh you know hypocrisy but they
they can't fall back
and say well this is trump's fault i'm
sorry orange man is gone
literally pelosi is trying to do that
they're trying to resurrect the
boogeyman but it's just not going to
work you know you know
banning him from twitter sure did
backfire on the left because trump would
be tweeting right now he's silent
yep nothing it's nothing and you know
what i would say
president trump if you're watching me
remember me i used to be your
congressman because mar-a-lago was in my
district
stay silent allow them as napoleon
would say never interfere with your
enemy when they are destroying
themselves
what um what was this executive order
that biden signed that's
screwing with the border right now well
he basically has said one of the things
was that there will be no deportations
uh and
our attorney general sued him on that
but he is also
you know you guys won right yeah we were
on that we we have a stay on that so we
can continue to deport
but one of the things that he did was he
said that this whole thing about
you must stay on the southern side of
the border in order to be processed for
your asylum
that's over now and so now they
understand that
they can do the asylum processing in the
united states of america that's why
they're flooding in
and we have gone back to the catch and
release system where
you know everything about this covet
but yet you had 108 illegal immigrants
that tested positive for covet in
brownsville texas
and they were taken to a bus station and
they were released
so is the buying administration serious
about covet i would think that you would
not allow 108 illegal immigrants to just
flow right into the state there's a lot
of hypocrisy
tons and it's it's kind of crazy how
often we can all bring it
up and it doesn't seem to change but
what i do notice is that one of the
areas of
hypocrisy is the the woke critical race
theory type people the progressives
they use the phrase latin x something
that most latinos don't
recognize or even use and what's
fascinating is
the shift in the southern counties in
texas yes
mainly latino went for trump yes
dramatically
that was a huge that was a huge story of
the november 2020 election
in texas uh and and my theory was that
kind of like the mentality of
paratroopers paratroopers jump in behind
enemy lines
and so why didn't we just go and take
our message into the areas where they
thought they were strong
into the rio grande valley and talk
about our principles and values talk
about
the open borders talk about illegal
immigration talk about strong families
strong small business entrepreneurship
better education opportunities
not defunding the police talk about the
threats on the drug cartels and guess
what
they're like yeah and when you look at
the policies of president trump where
you had
record unemployment in the hispanic
community when you look at the oil and
gas
industry that was thriving which meant
good paying jobs black white hispanic it
doesn't matter
then they say yeah we like this
direction
now all of a sudden this joe biden comes
in
and their communities are being
threatened the drug cartels are being
empowered the illegal immigrants are
coming back in which means
a taxing on them and their tax base to
provide
you know additional services it means a
lack of safety and security
so they are alienating further
this area that they once thought they
completely control
this is a big big story of the of uh
the november election as you mentioned
the you know trump winning over more
votes for minority communities across
the board most in 60 years
yeah that's something to stress i mean
when they talk about donald trump as a
racist then explain to me
how he had the most minority electoral
support
of any republican in 60 years at running
for president and
who did he lose he lost white voters
yeah
and so i wonder who is really buying
into this this message
about immigration you know trump is
racist for wanting to uh
you know deport illegal immigrants and
things like that certainly isn't the
minority communities that are literally
on the borders who are experiencing what
happens with
unfunded or the black communities
they're going to see
their wages being depressed their job
opportunities going to be gone as well
and they saw that they were thriving in
the trump administration but look at it
and think about it this way the suburban
white woman
that was told again orange man bad he's
a nasty person he doesn't like women his
tree
tweets are horrible now all of a sudden
the suburban soccer mom
has to ask herself why is this six foot
two
gender dysphoric biological male gonna
be on the soccer field with my daughter
that's not what they voted for well they
should have paid attention to what they
were voting for
but but again now that's why it comes
back to that poll that you just talked
about
how a lot of people don't see joe biden
as being
capable of being the president and all
of these things that he is
implementing by way of the leftist
agenda and it's going to be the same
thing for young people
i mean i think that with president trump
you had a
cultural president connected with young
people he's a little rough or whatever
but
that's something that you get with a new
yorker but now you have someone that
you know if if you think that free
equals freedom you're horribly wrong
yeah one of the one of the main issues
that seems to have been lost on the left
is the economics of mass migration and
illegal immigration
that even bernie sanders was criticizing
back in 2015.
here's this guy he's the champion of the
left and the progressives and in 2015 he
said
open borders is a koch brothers proposal
he was basically saying these big
billionaire industrialists
want cheap labor with no rights with no
with you know that
they can get in there for below minimum
wage and they need these policies in
order to do it
and there were big scandals i remember i
watched a documentary where some of
these companies would bring in illegal
immigrant labor
promise them a bunch of money and at the
end of the month just call immigration
and have them all deported
and they were exploiting these loopholes
they wanted that that porous border for
this
for this purpose but that means these
factories were actually taking away
good paying jobs for low-skilled labor
in these areas for
working-class americans you're
absolutely right and that's why you see
the u.s chamber of commerce that it's
all about
you know the open borders and the
illegal immigration that's why you see a
lot of these big businesses and
corporations don't want e-verify
what is what is he verified he verifies
the system by which people are
registered and you can track
individuals they don't want that and so
you have
you have some partisanship on either
side with this
this issue uh one people want to bring a
new victim class
they want a new voter base the other
side wants to have a cheap labor base
but in the end who is getting squeezed
and who's going to be the most affected
your middle to lower income levels
blacks and hispanics
are going to be the ones to suffer with
the scourge of illegal immigration
i like what you said about free does not
mean freedom because
we built a system of law and rule that
has enabled us to be free
to experience freedom in our system like
you have to abide by a strict rule of
law
so that you don't get jumped when you're
walking down the street and you can feel
free outside
just dispensing with the rules in this
antarctic free society does not lead to
freedom as we understand it
no it doesn't and and when you think
about what was going on i mean you grew
up in chicago and i remember seeing the
riots that were happening in chicago
with these
black lives matter social justice
warriors and they were going in and
busting up
all of those stores on the uh the the
million miles
magnificent magnificent mile and what
were they saying this is how we're going
to get our reparations
that's that a woman is actually quoted
as saying that she didn't care when when
asked about the right she said
this is reparations as far as she's
concerned there's a video of a guy
firing a gun into the window of one of
these shops trying to steal
luxury merchandise look i'm not a big
fan
of like luxury brands i think it's you
know can be a bit pompous
but i'm i i think it's fine people have
that stuff i don't think someone should
go and shoot guns and steal it because
they think they're owed something
no but it was defended in the media and
that's the sad thing and that's the
breakdown
of the rule of law and order remember
that
you know when um john locke
wrote his second treatise of government
and he talked about
this thing you know that was completely
different it was natural rights theory
that was different from divine rights
theory and john locke came out and said
that there are three inalienable rights
that we have from our creator it's life
liberty
and property and what do you see
happening with the left
all you got to do is go to the communist
manifesto by karl marx
it is about taking away that individual
right to property
and that is what you see happening in
america now it's a wealth redistribution
scheme that says
i don't care how much you work hard tim
i don't care how successful your podcast
is
i don't care how well you're doing here
ian it is our right as the government to
come in and take it away from you and
redistribute it to someone else
that ain't freedom i had a good
conversation with uh with a socialist
i think it was the socialist party of
great britain or something and uh
they basically said when when i brought
up that point about property
they said no no you don't understand in
socialism you're allowed personal
property
it's very different from you like a
watch right so so when they said they're
banning private property i'm like so
well i can't have clothes
and they're like no no that's personal
property private property is like a
building
and i'm like okay so let's let's let's
try and find that line of where you
split
personal property from private property
they were trying to explain that private
property in their system means the means
of production
the the factory nationalizing production
well so here's the question i had okay
well i do my work by filming myself with
a camera
the camera is my means of production my
factory essentially
should that camera be owned by someone
else or should it be my personal
property
didn't really have a good answer for it
because you there it's it's a it's a
weasel word excuse
for some justification for seizing
people's private property absolutely
personal property is meaningless your
shoes okay but what about my car
what about my bike what about my food my
refrigerator my home
where do you draw the line and they said
ultimately well we don't necessarily
know
of course you don't know your system is
magic it doesn't make sense and it's
broke
it has never been successful and so
let's take that
philosophy and let's over plant it to
the last
year dealing with this covet issue
show me in the constitution where any
elected official has the enumerated
power
to decide who or what is essential in
the united states of america
show me you've done it but yeah but show
me in the constitution coming back to
your state about the rule of law and
freedom
show me in the constitution where it
says that any elected official
politician can come to you and say shut
down
your business shut down your livelihood
but yet i will continue to be paid
isn't the 14th amendment barring them
from doing that
that people must be treated equal
protection under the law yeah absolutely
but but see when you have the ability to
redefine the law or fundamentally
transform the law
and say that well you know we don't
really know what it is but we're kind of
deciding as we go along and if we
continue to have
and let me say this correctly when we
move from being people to being sheeple
we are allowing ourselves to be
fear-mongered and intimidated into
surrendering
our everyday liberties and rights
remember what benjamin franklin said
those who would surrender essential
liberty for temporary security will in
the end deserve neither liberty nor
security
and lose both and lose both they won't
deserve either so that's what we're
talking about when we say free does not
equal freedom
if you want something to give you
something for free you're surrendering
your freedom to that person
let me ask you you you bring up the
constitution and uh election elected
officials
right to tell you to close your business
my response is i think the 14th
amendment says equal protection
under the law do you think that's fair
to say that these politicians
uh these states are by chance violating
the constitution of the united states
absolutely they are and and as a matter
of fact you have had
several state supreme courts that have
come back and said
hey what our governors did with these
mandates edicts orders and decrees were
unconstitutional
we are a constitutional republic that
means we are governed by a rule of law
we are not a constitutional monarchy
where someone sits up like ram sees
pharaoh
and says so let it be anything so let it
be done and we're supposed to all fall
down like subjects we're citizens
and and i think that's what's so
important if there's one message
i can get to the young people you've got
to understand
the structure of this government you've
got to understand
the roles and responsibilities of the
respective branches
you've got to understand your rights
because if you don't
they're going to be just absolutely
confiscated let me well let's
i want to read for you a quote all right
this is a very a very important quote
from a very smart man who said
perhaps law-abiding states should bond
together and form a union of states that
will abide by the constitution
texas gop chairman alan west said in a
statement friday night
the texas gop will always stand for the
constitution and for the rule of law
even while others don't very funny joke
i know it's your quote
but uh you said that and just in the
context of what has been happening
not just and this was in the context of
the election and the supreme court's
ruling yeah against the state of texas
and
the other states coming together about
the unconstitutional actions right right
looking at that looking at the bigger
picture uh uh i think it's fair to say
we are seeing the constitution
be used well i won't be too disrespect
disrespectful myself but let's just say
they are absolutely disrespecting
violating and turning the constitution
into swiss cheese
completely so you you had this statement
that many said you are essentially
calling for secession
and it actually sounds like you were
accusing them of secession
you know you know this is right you got
the declaration of independence right
there
and the constitution yeah see it's
falling apart because you know i'll take
it everywhere i go
so uh let me see let me go to where's
that whole preamble thing
oh there it is so the preamble we the
people of the united states in order to
what
form a more perfect union and in order
to form a more perfect union what's the
first thing we do establish justice
so again coming back to that piece that
i wrote yesterday constitutionalist
versus secessionists
the people that are succeeding or the
people that are violating this document
the people that are constitutional and
law abiding like we saw in this past
election cycle
you have several states where governors
secretaries of state
and courts did unconstitutional actions
the only people that can change election
law
is the legislative branch yes but yet
that's not what we saw happen so
that's not a debatable thing i mean
youtube is not going to cancel you out
unless youtube doesn't understand
the constitution but yet we have people
that allowed that to happen
absolutely we had numerous incidents i
think 24 states
yes where outside of the legislature
election rules were changed and that's
wrong
some of these states didn't challenge it
many of them did and
somehow none of them got standing or
or ruled on the merits and that's
horrible because if you're a state of
texas and you join with 17 other states
and you are going to constitutional
right
petition your government for redress of
grievance against another state there's
only one court you can go to
the court of original jurisdiction is
the united states supreme court
united states supreme court cannot say
to texas that we're not going to hear
the case they didn't
that's but that's your job right and so
again we have this
abdication of the rule of law and those
constitutional duties and
responsibilities
and for those people that want to say
that you know i'm talking about
succeeding
well then what was the national popular
vote interstate compact all about
where these blue states were going to
come together and undermine the
electoral college
okay which is in the constitution is in
the constitution so there are the real
successions ian you had
yeah i feel like they're using martial
laws like impetus to
to you know buy bypass rights
and and they're they're acting like
covet is such um
an emergency that they have to do this
now you
served as lieutenant colonel and i
imagine you understand the
the necessity for martial law in certain
situations if we were under attack
or if something horrible you know yeah
nine eleven yeah worst case scenario
power grid goes out
invasion whatever yeah like martial
lights went out in texas just recently
would be and in the past have been
stripped of their constitutional rights
you know habeas corpus was suspended
abraham lincoln yeah so
but this ain't it this ain't it folks
okay
let's honestly talk about covet we're
talking about something that has a 99.96
recovery rate okay even the cdc came out
last fall and said
that uh out of all the deaths attributed
to covet
only six percent were because of 94
percent were based of
basically people that died with covet
they had other co-morbidities
they were obese high blood pressure
heart disease
uh type 2 diabetes all of these things
so
well so i'll push back a little bit okay
and and give my standard clarification
i guess the the only way i can really
break down kind of a middle ground on
this assessment is
these people would have lived longer had
it not been for coveted
so some of these people that have renal
failure and a lot of conservatives have
pointed but how much longer
i mean how do we know that i mean some
some of these i mean you look at the
preponderance of the deaths with covet
we're above 70 years of age yes
absolutely
okay so i mean so very strong is that is
that the reason why you
go in and suspend the constitutional
rights
of an entire country well so so here's
the point i want to make
even if it were that kovit was the
the number one cause outside of any
comorbidity the answer is still
no we we we have to respect as a
community when we set certain
we have emergencies but even when you
look at the grand total uh
i think it's 97.5 recovery when you
include those over 70
i mean that's still ridiculously high
granted that's
looking at a lot of deaths that you know
2.5 percent out of 330 million
yeah but every year you average almost
600 000 with heart disease
right and obesity yes and we do every
year we don't lock down the country we
don't
mandate calisthenics programs no we do
not shut things down because people are
doing things that
can be arguably socially contagious like
bad habits
think about how stupid it is okay so we
know obesity is one of the things that
you know together with covet causes
death but yet we're going to shut down
gems
right yeah i mean keep alcohol not only
that but
vitamin u like a vitamin d dr himself
we lock everyone in their houses yeah
stay inside and we know that kovit was
spreading more inside than outside
yeah we lock everyone in their homes
with no sun with no exercise
and a higher chance of rate of spreading
covert what did people think was going
to happen
so it was it but but see the the thing
and and again
no emergency is grounds to suspend the
rule of law
so what this was was a grand experiment
in
control what do you think that you think
the civil war was was grounds for
suspending the constitution abraham
lincoln did it
i know but i would not have yeah i mean
you cannot suspend you know people's
habits corpus but
you know the interesting thing is that
you had a
a situation where you know we were
fighting against each other
with within you know the same spaces i
mean
you know here we have you know west
virginia and you know being on one side
of virginia is on another side and
pennsylvania's on the other side
but still you don't suspend
constitutional rights no matter what and
and that goes back to what uh franklin
delano roosevelt
did with the japanese americans with the
internment camps
i understand the criticality of the
situation but you do not suspend
people's constitutional rights agreed
but they have put their toes in the
water
and they found that the water was very
receiving
yeah and so what is the next step well
have you heard of
this the great reset the world economic
forum yeah i mean i think that the u.s
has been co-opted by the federal reserve
and
global banking establishments and
they're using our military and our
economy and where do you find the
premise of central banking
switzerland and the bank of
international settlements call mark's
communist manifesto
is that really in there it is
centralized control of banks
just like centralized control of
education just like progressive tax
system
you know we have a tax system in the
united states of america that's based
upon the principles of karl marx
a progressive tax system and so again
there's so much of this out there that
if a dumb old boy from georgia who used
to jump out of airplanes for a living
if i can figure this out you really
smart people can figure this out well
let's yeah i couldn't fly airplanes i
jumped out oh wow so let's we'll have a
conversation on this because
uh there are a lot of things that are
more liberal or left-wing policies that
i agree with
but my challenge one of the things that
always leaves me more of a moderate in
the middle is
implementation so when i look at the
progressive tax
i think about people like george soros i
think about the koch brothers i think
about
uh did i say bezos i said soros bezos
extremely powerful individuals who have
so much wealth
they've actually shut out the working
classroom election process so i'll give
you some examples
mike bloomberg dumping 500 600 million
dollars into the election
oh we saw that with mark zuckerberg
yeah into texas to directly to
a uh a county clerk's office so no
we should not allow that to happen so a
few years ago i was very much
i i should say for a long a large
portion of my life i was very much in
favor of a progressive tax system where
we have a higher percentage for people
who make more
because of i guess arguably called the
law of power right power attracts
power the more money you make the easier
it is for you to make more money
and this money allows you to invest
reduce risk
live comfortably if you make 10 million
dollars it's very very easy for you to
make more because you have so much
access
and things like that so the ic i would
disagree with you
disagree yes how is it that a kid
that doesn't even have a college
education can grow up and be a
multi-millionaire in the united states
of america
they can yeah and so it's about the
equality of opportunity
i i what you're talking about is the
corruption of power
and and and and so what it takes i mean
much the same as sir edmund burke said
all that's necessary uh for to triumph
over evil is for good men to do nothing
so if we continue to have a political
elite system
which i think even amran kind of wrote
about if we have a political elite
system that teams up with the
the corporate cronies and the elites of
corporations like what we see with big
tech right now then you see a usurpation
so my view of the progressive tax was
it in a simplistic kind of way you can
create a system makes it harder for
people with extreme wealth
to utilize that wealth as an advantage
over the working class in the arena of
politics that's my core reason
and and i agree with you that like i
said it's the corruption of power
here's the problem giving the money to
the government doesn't solve the problem
because now you have another monopoly
that has
all of that power and so you've got
permanent bureaucrats
that would take that money from the
ultra wealthy and then just
maintain their control so you know
ultimately while i still
kind of view that as a better
alternative simply because
there's up many bureaucrats versus the
one billionaire who can flood the zone
with money and shut out the working
class
i i ultimately still see it as a problem
that needs to be solved beyond we don't
allow them to flood the zone
exactly so that's the other point i
would make is maybe the solution is more
simply
some kind of restriction somehow i
honestly don't know how you do it
well this is this is where i think this
is where i think it starts
is you know one of the things that mark
levine wrote about in his book liberty
amendments is term limits
on members of congress house and senate
because the longer people are up here in
washington d.c the richer they get
i mean ask yourself how could a young
lady from
brooklyn new york there was a bartender
have a posh
penthouse apartment in washington dc and
you know who i'm talking about yeah
isn't it like three grand a month or
something or more a lot okay it's a lot
and so you know when i was in congress
10 years ago i had a
you know you know fully furnished little
basement little i called it the bat cave
didn't even have a window they're
they're members of congress sleeping in
their offices
yeah it's a big problem so how does it
and and i disagree with that
uh so how is it that you know this
person that was a former bartender now
has a
posh penthouse apartment over there by
washington nationals park
i'm telling you it's this and so is that
is that marrying of the the corporate
cronyism to the political elitism that's
what we all should come together how do
we
i agree you know i hear it from the
progressives i hear from the young turks
and i completely agree with them
the problem is you know like the
citizens united ruling which i'm sure
you're familiar with
you know you've got these super pacs
these political action committees
how do you tell someone they can't spend
their money to buy a commercial i mean
it's a free speech i don't mind people
about you know buying the money for the
commercial i don't want them buying a
politician
well how do they do that you make sure
that they cannot buy a politician you
pass the laws like what we're doing in
texas right now in our legislative
session
that says mark zuckerberg you don't get
to come back in here and dump a hundred
thousand dollars
in harris county so that they can go out
and number one try to do universal mail
and ballots which is against texas
election law
and they expand curbside voting which is
completely against
against texas election law so that's
what you do
our states have power that's why you
have a 10th amendment
it says all the powers not delegated to
the federal government
are reserved to the states and to the
people so our states
need to assert their powers and make
sure that like i said coming back to hr1
and some of these other things to being
passed
constitutional nullification was pretty
much so passed in north dakota well
let's talk about hr one
yeah right so i i it passed the house
passed the house it's not yet gone to
the senate right well it's over to the
senate but the thing is right now this
is the concern right now the senate's
still
you have to have 60 votes to end the
cloture which means that you can go into
the final
uh vote if they change that and get rid
of the filibuster then you got
problems now what keeps the democrats
right now from going straight to uh
getting rid of filibuster joe manchin
and kirsten sinema
west virginia and arizona have said they
will not support getting rid of the
filibuster
so we'll see what happens but they can
just all of a sudden snap their fingers
and be like yeah no more filibusters and
now it's allowed
now that would be 51 votes or 50 votes
in a tiebreaker
and the tiebreakers kamala harris and
see that's why the senate was set up to
be
the upper body of our legislation
legislative branch
and it will require 60 votes because
what the founding fathers want to make
sure sure you got the
representation of the people that's
majority but over here in the senate
that's the clearinghouse
so everything can't just get rammed
right through you really have to have a
deliberative body
so let's uh break break down for me hr1
i've read a bit of it there are some
things that actually like but there are
some
really alarming things it's incredibly
alarming because hr1 nationalizes
elections you talk about nationalizing
production and
confiscation of property what hr one
does is takes elections away from the
states it says that
all across united states of america
there will be universal mail and ballots
it says that there will be no voter
registration reviews anywhere in the
united states of america no picture id
for voting in the united states of
america felons can vote there will be
same-day
voter registration and voting there will
be online voter registration
and it sets up an independent commission
for redistricting states right now do
their own redistricting why do the
democrats want to take over
redistricting
because republicans control 62 of 99
legislative bodies
across the united states of america so
the republicans are control of the
political reshaping for the next 10
years
of the respective states the democrats
don't like that so h.r
1 is completely unconstitutional
in every way shape form or fashion now
of course the democrats are going to
throw some nice things in there to try
to
you know entice you to do it they're
going to give it a real nice name for
the people's act
but it is an oxymoronic title with the
emphasis on the word [ __ ]
because what it does it takes away the
ability of states
to run their elections what uh what good
stuff did they put in it
i hadn't seen any really well uh i'm in
favor of felons being able to
have the right to vote oh yeah you
mentioned that it sounds like you viewed
as a negative
i look you know i think it was uh
don't do the don't do the crime if you
can't do the time remember sammy davis
jr saying that for the you know serpico
uh there has to be consequences and
ramifications from
prison law you know i mean i i the way i
see it is
there there's there's two really big
things for me when it comes to felons
if you commit a crime and then you are
you know
you're handed down some kind of
punishment penalty or something from a
judge
you serve your time for the crime your
rights should be restored you're right
to own a gun and your right to vote in
my opinion
so should a rapist be able to own a gun
and vote i think the answer is yes
after they've paid their their that
decision they can't go there well what
if what if they serve i got two
daughters so i can't go there but
so you're not going to disagree on that
one respect because first of all you
know if you
if you did that to my daughter you you
got to deal with me
right okay of course yeah there's
there's certain things but
you know beyond the courts and again i
don't like to blanket
all you know if you want to look at
certain offenses
where if someone does their time then
they are restored i agree but to make
the blanket statement
i can't and it's state by state right
now right like in some states felons can
vote
or yeah i think that virginia is one of
those states that
and i think there's a reason why i think
i think that's actually a really good
point i think there's probably some
crimes where you do not get your rights
restored you know so
we had a conversation the other day
about the second amendment
and i said if the constitution says your
right to keep in barramundi not be
infringed
there's no caveats in that it doesn't
say if you're a felon
so as far as i i can if as far as i see
it i mean
while you're in prison or on probation
or on parole whatever it is
you are serving punishment you can't
have a gun but i think once you've paid
your debt to society your rights should
be restored well again
and and i would say that if you're a
person that went out and committed every
aggravated assault you know if you
committed a a gun related crime
i don't know if i want you to come back
and get or spousal abuse or something
like that
but let's let's talk you know it's a
good point that you're trying to think
it's funny that i might be further right
on 2a than you
i don't think so i'm on the board of the
national association
but but you talk about h.r 8 which is
another thing that just passed
the united states house of
representatives and so think about what
hra does
let's say you got a friend that
you know is is waiting to get a firearm
but they just had someone break into
their house and you want to you know
hey here's my you know p365 sig or
here's my glock 43.
do you know that you're now a felon
because of what was just passed
well so it didn't pass the senate yet
though right no but it's passed in the
house
right and so again you know we got to
understand
when we say i hadn't passed the senate
but what we have to start thinking about
what is the mentality what is the
philosophy
of governance of the progressive
socialist left
because that's what you see happening in
the house of representatives
h.r 127 h.r 130. i know that you got
firearms here but do you know that
sheila jackson lee says that you cannot
have any loaded firearms in your house
what that's hr1 what's the point of
having it
well i'm sorry i mean i'm the government
yeah
i know better than you what's uh did it
pass the house 130.
hr 127 hr 130 have not come up hr 8
was passed hrh and so this bans the
private it effectively bans the private
sale of firearms because
you would need a federal background
check no matter what so there are
certain places where
i'm sorry that makes literally no sense
they like to call it the gun show
loophole
but it's literally not a loophole it's
just the private sale so let's put this
way
there are cert many states that allow
the private transfer because it makes
sense if you live in
west virginia is a good example the
middle of nowhere in west virginia in
the mountains
and you got a neighbor who's you know
maybe two miles down the road
and he's like look man we're getting
really bad
30 to 50 feral hugs and you're like well
why don't i sell you this here you know
firearm so you can keep your property
safe help keep your kids safe and your
crops or whatever or even i'll loan it
to you
oh yeah you can't do that either you
can't do that either right right now you
can
in west virginia so long as you're not
giving it to someone who is ineligible
so there is still a responsibility on
you if you're like here i'm gonna you
know let you this rifle and it turns out
the guy's a felon now you're in trouble
i'm gonna sell it to you but now under
hr8
you would have to go to an ffl and then
do the the the ni what is it with the
next background check for the individual
thing 4473
right and then go through a standard
transfer now me personally
i don't live out the middle of nowhere
so i don't think
if i was going to do a transfer i'd go
to an ffl anyway just so it's a clean
transfer and my name's off of it
but i certainly understand why there
might be a guy who's like
for his brother i'm gonna give you this
weapon to guard you know the you know
your your property or the the five acres
in the back i'm letting you use
hr rate would make that illegal yeah so
it's it's it's make you a felon
yeah that's messed up ten years like
maybe like even if
maybe it could be reasonable if it was
like an administrative fine of some sort
yeah but
but not even that but think about this
okay when my uh my oldest daughter
was going to southern methodist
university she was getting her master's
in biochemistry and hamahama because
she's really smart like a mom
and so she had to stay late at night to
do you know lab experiments
lab works whatever and so smu is located
close to downtown dallas and so i loaned
her my nine millimeter
said keep it you know so that when
you're walking out to your car in
parking lot you just make sure that
you're safe
hr8 makes me a felon for saying to my
daughter here
take that's nine millimeter so that you
can be safe when you're when you're over
there late at night
and i think your daughter knows how to
use a nine millimeter my daughter has
fired a barrett
okay she's daddy's girl both of them
and so 50 bmgs yeah and so this is my
concern
and again this is why i'm so glad to be
here with young people
is that you are seeing a slow usurpation
confiscation of your rights by people
that have a mentality
of a philosophy of governance that has
never done anything
to promote freedom you mentioned earlier
uh term limits
i'm a huge advocate for that yeah 12
years how would you say
12 years okay how would we do this this
is how you do well i mean they're not
going to vote for it themselves
okay and so that's why the founding
fathers were brilliant
it was almost as if when they sat down
200 and some odd years ago
and wrote the constitution they said how
can these stupid idiots
screw it up and so they figure out every
single fail-safe backdoor
method and so therefore they came up
with article five
which is a convention of states not a
constitutional convention a convention
of states
whereby if you get 34 states and they
assigned delegates
they can come and they can recommend an
amendment to the constitution
like term limits on federal house of
representatives and senators but if you
get 38 states states can actually change
the constitution states can amend the
constitution that's article 5.
so one of the things that you should
look at is why these guys stand up here
forever
you know you know there are certain
states out there to have term limits on
their state house members state senators
everything's working fine so if you have
12 years
up here and i base that on two terms as
a senator that's 12 years
six terms in the house of
representatives that's 12 years and it's
not transferable
you don't get to say well you know i've
been over here for 10 years in the house
and now i'm going to run for senator
and i'll get another 12 years no it's 12
years total so we need 36 states
um 34 states 34 states and you can
recommend
an amendment to the congress and then
the senate would have to yeah the houses
said
which they voted on so we need 38 38 and
do we need a majority in each state just
51 percent
no you 38 states to to come together and
and
vote to have the participant in an
article five constitution states
that that causes convention that's just
the legislative bodies
that's just the legislative bias right
now i think we're 16.
okay for for republican states now the
republicans control the majority
legislatures done but right now we're at
16.
wow well so let me i can loot this back
into the gun control thing because you
mentioned
they could recommend a an amendment to
the constitution at 38 they can get it
second amendment says the right to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed
but in new jersey if you bear arms you
will be arrested and you'll be a felon
yeah in new york and in illinois and
california
your right to keep and bear arms has
been infringed
quite literally as worse as bad as it
could be and guess what that comes back
to exactly what i said
law-abiding constitutional states
that's what i talked about in that
article constitutionalist
versus secessionist the people that are
going against our constitution
they're the secessionists so when you
look at a state that is telling you
that you cannot have your constitutional
right i don't understand why anyone in
any state will sit back and say
well okay you don't get to give it and
take it just the same as you cannot tell
me as a private business owner
i must shut down my business there was a
a post on the donald form it's it's they
changed the name it's patriots.win now
where they were talking about the right
to keep and bear arms has been infringed
and there was there was a lot of
sentiment saying ammunition magazines
all that sort of stuff and so a lot of
the sentiment
i found to be i'll just put it this way
uh i won't i won't comment my opinion
but people were saying
then express your right to bear arms and
and gra and gain judicial standing to
sue
in defense of the second amendment
absolutely that's a bold statement
but think about it but but there are two
cases dc versus heller
uh richard heller and i know him
personally the
you know was afraid he just wanted to be
able to have a firearm to defend himself
in washington d.c they told him he
couldn't do it
he went to the supreme court he won the
case otis mcdonald
black man chicago took on the city of
chicago mcdonald's versus chicago
that was that was relatively recent
wasn't it that was back in the
80s yeah back in the 80s but a black man
just wanted to be able to defend himself
in his home and he took the city of
chicago to the supreme court so it's
already been done
it's already been taken so we have
proven that it it has standing
across the the united states as standing
in states and local municipalities but
yet we still allow
people to undermine the most important
right that you have because the founding
fathers understood
that your first amendment rights the
freedom of speech press expression
you know symbol freedom of religion
petitioned the government for rejection
grievances
those are passive rights if you don't
have a mechanism
to defend and secure those rights
they're going to get taken away from you
and that's why they have the second
amendment the great modern thinker
dave chappelle said the second amendment
is just there in case the first one
doesn't work out
he's absolutely right that his amazing
statement dave chapel is amazing but
it's absolutely right brilliant
and you think about there have been only
two instances in the united states of
america of revolution
okay and that was the american
revolution
and in texas and both of those
revolutions started
because of what gun control gun control
the british were marching toward concord
massachusetts to destroy
weapons and armaments factory on april
the 19th
of 1775 they were met at lexington green
because they understood
if you're armed your citizen if you're
disarmed you're subject
october the 2nd 1835 in gonzales texas
the mexican cavalry shows up
because they want a cannon back that
they are given to the people of gonzalez
to protect themselves against the
comanche raiders
because they were hearing about this
thing called a revolution amongst the
texans
the texans replied with that famous
response come and take
it wow those are the only two instances
and so this is i'm just all you leftists
that are out there
this is a very bad thing that you all
are doing
well so hold on the the far left they're
super pro 2a
it's the establishment suburban liberal
types
they're so the larger portion of the
left voter the democrat voter
absolutely in favor of gun control but
that element of progressives the
socialist types
i mean they're armed to the teeth they
might not be as nearly as skilled or
well-trained or physically fit
but you can see it on twitter their
advocacy yeah that's kind of like the
guy that was part of an antifa black
class matter
a rally down in austin texas and he had
a i think an ak-47 he went up to a car
and started shaking his ak-47 and inside
the car
was an army soldier that's right and he
popped him yep
so look they absolutely
are in favor of guns but again they
don't seem to be as well trained
there are some groups that are there are
there are left-wing
socialist and communist militia types
where you can tell these guys have real
training but they are
few and far between yeah but if you go
to your average antifa person
oh they're they're all about weapons i
mean they show up with explosives
they show up with guns in portland and
lasers and lasers
yeah but we recently had there was a
story of a woman who was in portland
during the riots she had a she had i
think she had a glock 17.
they want guns you had that guy um what
was the guy who went to the ice facility
in tacoma
oh yeah willem uh yeah that's bronson
yeah he he he had himself a ghost uh
a ghost gun that he brought and was
using against an ice facility
these are leftist this guy was a vowed
antifa but see the thing is that
and and you you delve into another
subject
is that what antifa black lives matter
does
is going to be acceptable but if you
have the
the the constitutionalist the
law-abiding legal gun owner
those are the people that the other side
does not want to have
the firearms and so there's a hypocrisy
in that
uh regardless and i think that is the
danger that we see
so there was a the military perspective
if you were looking at this like a
combat situation would you then
infiltrate the black lives matter antifa
segment so that you could
utilize it to overthrow or propagate
your victory
well i mean that's one of the forms of
maneuvers infiltration but
we already know who they are we already
know what their structure is
i mean look at the the silliness of the
fact that
you know facebook twitter and all these
other guys they want to kick
you know conservatives off of these
platforms but yet antifa black lives
matter
they're still operating on these
platforms i mean the the iranian
mullah over there uh ayatollah khamenei
is still operating on twitter
so again we know everything about them
it's so
interesting is that all of these folks
that were participating in january the
6th
their houses are getting raided they're
being picked up just like that being
arrested
all of these folks that we see over a
year or more
that have been doing these you know
attacks raids and continue to do so
nobody's arresting them there was this
uh thing that happened with
a journalist at new york times named
taylor lorenz tucker carlson it became
this huge story
and i took the approach of you know we
shouldn't engage in this
kind of you know specific name calling
i understand you want to be critical of
a journalist because what they do
but i was pointing out that you've got
to go after the ideas and the
institutions not the individual
now a lot of people told me i was wrong
they said tim they started the fight and
we're fighting back and
my response to this is after everything
we've seen
with the the january six people they're
getting they're getting the house raided
they're getting smeared in the press
relentlessly some of them can't even get
lawyers and i'm not talking about the
worst or the worse i'm talking about the
bumblebee at what point did you think
that
you were fighting symmetrical warfare
where you want an equal footing with
your opponent
you're not it's a double standard you're
second class
if you protest they call it a violent
riot you're an insurrectionist
and if antifa shows up with guns and
firebombs a federal building for
a hundred plus days they call it a
peaceful protest so at a certain point
to realize that the media apparatus will
villainize you
no matter what you do and you've got to
be very very strategic about how you
approach this
understand the rules by which they play
and exploit them for strategic victory
but if you throw totally right you throw
them on the same way they do you're
you're doing what they want and they're
winning because they made the rules it
reminds me of like
it very much reminds me of the matrix
yeah you got the idea of the blue pill
the red bill people who are in the
narrative people who aren't
and the agents for some reason super
fast super strong
but as they explain in the matrix they
still have to abide by all of the same
rules
they explain that neo who somehow gains
the abilities of these agents is just
understanding their rules and
controlling the matrix in the way that
the agents do
once you realize that then what is it
when you say
what does new say you're talking about
dodge bullets no i'm saying that once
you realize how the media narrative
works
you won't have to you won't have to yeah
and that's one of the things that you
know
lydia and i were talking about is you
know
read sun tzu definitely because you
have to have a strategic mindset to
understand exactly what you said
find the gaps find the means by which
you can exploit the other side find
their weaknesses
because if you continue to have the
frontal assault mentality
you're gonna get gunned down all you
gotta do is ask pickett about that
charge he just did you know right up
there i'll tell you one other weaknesses
the grammys if you really want to get
through these people write a hit song
and play the grammys next year because
that's what they need right now well so
at the grammys they did a pro
black lives matter pro riot performance
they had tamika mallory come out and say
we don't need allies we need accomplices
i mean it's outright advocacy for the
violent riots and
and so the interesting thing is when
you hear someone say black lives matter
and this is something i want to tell
everybody out there
the first thing you should respond and
say which black lives matter
that's right put them totally on defense
because
does candice owens matter to these
people no i don't think so i don't mind
you don't matter that's right
the 20 million black babies that have
been murdered in the womb since roe v
wade in 1973 don't matter the the blacks
that are killing themselves
in gang violence in chicago where they
don't matter the
the young black kids that are being
locked out of schools because of these
teachers unions
and they're falling further they don't
matter and so again
when we have to take that title
and find a way to flip it on them and
put them on the defense and just say
which black lives matter
i mean i i will say strategically for
for one i think it's probably obvious to
you the abortion argument never works
because
it's just the the view of what
constitutes life to the left
and to liberals and conservatives is
different but see this is what i
say i say okay so you guys are so woke
and everybody's a white supremacist
everybody's racist and all this kind of
stuff
well who founded planned parenthood
margaret sanger a white supremacist
a racist who spoke at ku klux klan
rallies referred to blacks as
undesirables and we
73 of planned parenthood clinics are in
black neighborhoods
so why why is she canceled they did
cancel her
who they they disavowed market singer
who the planned parenthood
who the the the people who had planned
numerous people at planned parenthood
like came out and said you know we
apologize for this and yeah
denounce their own history shut down
yeah wine is shut down
well you know that's not actually like
canceled culture may be a thing
for you no but but see they can disavow
it that's what i'm saying yeah
so if you're going to go out and think
about okay so black lives matter
so why did you allow people to tear down
the statue of frederick douglass
in rochester new york why did you allow
really that's one of the few things that
really got to me especially well it got
to me too frederick
was amazing he's an incredible man why
would you allow
the the monument to the very first black
man that wore a uniform for the united
states of america the 54th massachusetts
regiment to be desecrated
did you who was did you see huh do you
know the guy's name
no the the this council culture they
went and desecrated the
do you know the name of the the guy in
the statue that got tore down frederick
douglass oh he was the first
black dude no no the 54th massachusetts
regiment was the first
black unit now i mean these were slaves
and freed men that didn't work for the
united states in the civil war
and they desecrated their memorial did
you see boston oh
you see the video of the two white
antifa women spray painting on property
and the two young black women are like
what are you doing yes stop doing this
and they're like don't worry we're
helping you
yeah you ain't helping me no as a matter
of fact there's a great book by jason
riley it says
it's called please stop helping us no
it's serious
he's a wall street journal that's a
great title yeah please stop so
something i often bring up uh my
experience in ferguson
and so for those that are you know
listening you made for me tell the story
but i'd love to tell it to you
colonel west i was in ferguson during
the riots and i witnessed
young black men linking arms to protect
the convenience store as
people were running around and looting
and they were begging they were saying
these people
telling the journalist sebastian walker
for at the time al jazeera now for vice
was there and he said what are you doing
tell me what's happening
and this this young black man says we
live here yeah these are our our this is
our communities our businesses these
people who are looting and riding don't
live here yeah
he gets a phone call and he gets all
he's like oh it's my mom
seb walker he's like don't worry i got
this and he takes the phone and i'm
standing there it's one of the
like just most profound amazing moments
i've experienced in a ride
this journalist takes the phone and he's
like yes hello
i'm with your son no he's being very
responsible he's a very good young man
and like the dude who is guarding the
convenience store from the writers
his mom he's getting vouched for by this
journalist it was amazing
but you know what happens next an
article gets written called in defense
of looting
which said that those people who came to
victimize this community
were actually just lashing out against
white supremacy this individual then
later wrote a book about it this person
of course is a white progressive
who knows nothing about this community
and what they actually wanted and was
being exploited and destroyed
i remember during the peak of the black
lives matter riots we had that rapper i
think his name was big mike
basically just exasperated saying why
did you come and burn down black
businesses in atlanta
this is not about black lives matter but
that's exactly what they were doing and
that's why you
should respond which black lives matter
you know i look over there you got on
that
piece of art then i'm afraid you ain't
black the george
the the the uh the g prime one yeah how
how utterly condescending yeah and
disrespectful that was
from joe biden to say that if you don't
have this mentality if you're not going
to allow yourself to be a victim
you're not black it's either like racism
or just
idiocy i think maybe probably both it is
both oh god i guess
racism is idiocy but the you know i love
it when you hear the democrats talk
about systemic racism
well let's just look at their history
the
the purveyors of systemic racism in the
united states of america has always been
the democrat party
okay in 1961 i mean i'm you know again
going back to the logan's run thing
i'm a little bit of a relic there's not
probably too many people that you can
find
that were born in a blacks only hospital
that's how you want
wow which one hugh spaulding hospital in
atlanta georgia
i grew up in the old fourth ward that's
dr king's neighborhood wow
and so i kind of know a little bit about
being black
and i kind of know a little bit about
equality of opportunity versus the
quality of outcomes
but when we have a party that has
systemically throughout history done
everything they possibly could to
destroy a certain community to now
the the the mechanism of destruction is
economic enslavement not physical
enslavement
now the mechanism is to to to try to
have this soft bigotry of low
expectations but you still get the same
result
victims and enslavement and so
when when people it's just
unconscionable to me
when i hear the democrats and the people
on the left
and they have these you know modern day
you know gatekeepers
called you know jesse jackson al
sharpton and the congressional back
caucus
trying to keep people as victims it just
turns my stomach
to hear them try to lecture us about
being racist have you seen what's going
on at these universities
absolutely the return of segregation
yeah absolutely i mean
why why would you want to sit around say
well we want the black student union we
want this and we want that
we want graduation separate graduations
separate proms and schools i mean why
are we going backwards
i i think that it's this is maybe it
sounds gonna sound crazy but a com
the communist chinese party uh chinese
communist party
is intentional they used to go after han
supremacist we had james lindsay on last
week he was telling us about this
it was all about supremacy han supremacy
are you the han supremacist or you are
han
or or not and so now it's white now the
word is white supremacist it's all about
dividing and i i mean they say they play
the long game this is like a 30 years
60-year psychological traumatic they're
establishing trauma
well if you go back and and listen to
joe biden's speech
joe biden's speech was not about unity
joe biden's speech was about conformity
joe biden's speech was saying we can be
unified if you conform
and if you don't conform now you're a
white supremacist and oh by the way
we're declaring war against you
so joe biden the incoming president of
the united states of america stood there
and basically said that they
are declaring war on the 74 to 75
million people that didn't vote for them
that's that's the ideological civil war
that we're in
and when you start to look at some of
these pieces of legislation being passed
out of the house wherever hr5 the
equality act hr5 has nothing to do with
equality
it has everything to do with a
progressive ideological agenda that
takes away
your freedom of speech and your freedom
of religion what is it hr5 basically
says that the lgbtq
agenda has been codified in the law if
you speak out against it if you are a
pastor you you you know specifically
yeah it adds uh it's a protected class
gender identity as a protected class in
the 1964 civil rights act
and there's a lot of muddy waters this
is very different from
when we you know when we litigated
non-discriminatory actions
it was one thing and this is the
argument here is
to say a gay couple wanting to get a
cake it's a different thing to be like
well you can do whatever you want
in the privacy of your own home it's not
our business to interfere with that so
you deserve
protection equal product under the law
and things like that with the equality
act
it would actually it opens up things
like high school athletics to biological
male so
so women's sports will now be opened up
title 9 is done
yeah yeah so so it's done it will be
done
uh what's title nine title nine is
women's sports women's athletics
and so scholarships and scholarships uh
as a matter of fact there's the case of
these young girls up in connecticut
where two
gender dysphoric biological males are
competing in the hundred meters or 200
meters
they just blew them away they broke
their records can we just understand i
mean it's a little
pie in the sky but like new sports like
you could have male sports female sports
transgender
no no no no no female sports you're
you're
it's right here baby but don't you care
about them yeah who cares about women's
rights
i do human rights so so actually let's
let's do this let's jump into this story
about the the us
army so oh yeah i know where you're
going so i mean you're
you might be uh you may be an expert on
you know the armed forces
you know having actually been in them
but we have a story from uh this is from
lad bible for some reason i chose live
bible
us army could reverse gender neutral
fitness tests
as research finds women struggle
so i've got i've i've well i've had
family in uh
i come from i actually come from a
military family everyone but me
basically was either married into or
served
and i remember hearing stories from i i
briefly lived just uh
just off of base housing in fort houston
uh fort uh is it fort use this yeah
virgin newport news
and i also briefly lived on fort carson
and colorado springs i know it very well
heard a lot of stories from people who
had no problem bringing up men or women
that women have a different standard
now first of all you know that in the
house of representatives you can't say
men and women they got rid of that
language yeah that's
nancy pelosi's rule she got a gendered
language what's the situation now
what do you say them you yeah you
how was that woman well so but anyway
let's we'll stay on the military thing
so i you know i remember hearing stories
from people who went through basic
training and they would say
you know the women would complain and be
given special leeway and things like
this
there were certain medical issues that
women had to be granted
special access to facilities that men
didn't get and so very much were given
special treatment
apparently at some point they wanted to
do gender-neutral
testing and my understanding correct me
if i'm wrong they were saying that
it used to be that women did well in
women's specific testing
and that means they would get promotions
once they went through
once they implemented gender neutral
testing where it was
even for both males and females the
women were struggling to score well
against the men
and not getting the promotions thus
creating inequity
inequity in equal outcome yeah see women
have the equal opportunity to compete in
the same tests
but because the standard was standard
the men just tended to do better on
physical tests meaning the women weren't
in the promotions so now
they're apparently going to reverse this
you you told me that you had stories you
knew people i don't know what your
thoughts on this would be
well let me let me put it in this
context
why do we have men's downhill skiing and
women's downhill ski
pretty innocuous thing i mean why don't
we just have men and women competing in
downhill skiing why are you so
something something for some reason men
can spin faster jump higher
yeah you have men's figure skating and
women's why do you have men's hockey and
women's hockey men's basketball
men way more bone density oh the shape
of the hips oh okay
so why is it when it comes to your
national security
that you want to say that there's no
difference i don't get it okay we are we
are very we are in serious trouble when
it comes to this listen
i i am absolutely all for
trans rights and lgbtq rights and the
respect of the individual and equality
under the law
but we have to be let me tell you
something tim in the united states
military i could put a guy
out for being overweight
you cannot join the military if you have
flat feet yep so now all of a sudden
we're going to say and this is what the
american psychiatric
association calls it gender dysphoria a
mental condition
so now we're saying that the united
states military has to accept people
with a mental condition
and then provide them hormonal therapies
at the taxpayer expense
what does that have to do with our
national security that's another one of
these feel good things
while as you just talked about the
chinese communist party
they're building their army they're
growing their hegemonic dominance
they're expanding their navy
and we're over here saying why can't we
be fair and have more equity
and and let everybody play in the
sandbox i have tremendous respect for
everybody who
serves or wants to serve but i think
that someone who's overweight could find
we could find a role for them that's a
net positive for us we don't have to be
in combat they don't have to be in
maybe one of these standard positions
that require the physical fitness but i
certainly think trans people
as well as overweight people could we
could we could absolutely find them to
be a
positive for our armed forces but now
you're telling me that the united states
military has to accept someone with
a condition a mental condition
determined by the american psychiatric
association which means they're gonna
have to provide counseling
they're gonna have to provide hormonal
therapies and all of this type of stuff
at the taxpayer expense
i don't think that's what the military
is is in existence for
the united states military is a
volunteer organization
we have to have standards we have to
have rules we have to have you know
guidelines because we are not looking at
being a
everybody to come and join and play
that's not what the united states
military is as a voluntary organization
now if it was a draft organization
that'd be something different if it was
an organization where we had obligatory
service then that's something different
but let me let me just put it in these
terms i'm 60 years of age
i'm five foot nine i'm about 206 pounds
this morning i got up and i knocked out
three and a half miles
did my you know push-ups and crunches
and everything if you put me
in a ring with ronda rousey
or any you know mixed martial arts yeah
you know they probably could get in that
kick on me because you know i'm 60 maybe
i'm a little slow
but if i get one punch
to their head what's going to happen you
know i defer to
joe rogan on this one and uh you know he
talked about this quite a bit they got
mad at him for it but he pointed
out that men have bigger hands stronger
grit bigger joints
and it's my bone deficiency density it's
all of those things
it's rejecting power i i twitch muscle
twist
fiber i think there is an issue if we
are displacing
strong able-bodied individuals with
people who are not
fit to serve for a variety of reasons
but i also think that
you know in my personal opinion you know
i look at say like a trans man someone
who's born female
is on you know therapy and is now a you
know trans man
i think there's a there's a net positive
to anybody who's willing to serve this
country and we can
we can find a way to make that work now
that that being said
i also understand biological differences
between male and female
and i think there are reasons why we
tend not to have women in combat roles
though i think now we do this is right
that came because of the obama
administration once again it's about the
social engineering of our military
let me tell you something uh a bullet
doesn't know male or female there's no
doubt about it
but the one thing that my number one
standing order
when i was a battalion commander and we
ended up going to iraq in 2003 my number
one standing order was keep your bayonet
sharp
and why did i say keep you banned that
sharp because you never know when you're
going to have to go into close quarter
combat with the enemy
that's right so you know
along those lines as a leader uh as a
commander in the military
now if a woman were to be in a commander
world do you think you need the biggest
baddest dude like the tough
strong men to be commanders or could you
get small
female commanders that would be as good
or better
than men do you think there's well i
will tell you that
there is an example of leadership that
without a doubt is necessary
if you're going to be a commander of
combat troops
you got to kind of look like a combat
troop and let me put it in this
perspective
if i walked in here with you all today
and
i said that i'm a retired army
lieutenant colonel
and i had no i'm not picking at you but
i had hair like yours in
oh no you see but if i had hair like
yours in
and if i had a little pooch belly and
everything like that when you kind of
look and say scratch your head it's like
man he don't look like a
well not be honest be honest well let me
let me just
i'll just make a point i'll be honest
without would you say in the back of
your head man he
you see definitely retired well so you
remember you see what just happened with
uh tucker carlson and that marine
i know exactly what just happened you
got accused of being overweight out of
shape
you know and and again i don't think
that we should have the united states
military senior
officers and senior licensed uh men
attacking
a news personality yeah yeah i i agree
say that that
that goes against you know we're
supposed to be protecting freedom of
speech
let me say something in regards to like
this this you know army testing and
stuff
i've been skateboarding my whole life
i'm sorry but i i i actually worked with
uh some individuals who are part of an
organization i'll leave their name i
don't want anyone anyone get dragged but
uh i had a good friend who was one of
the best female skateboarders in the
world
at a certain time period i went to the x
games vip access we got to hang out she
was a really good friend of mine growing
up
and i got to listen to a top female pro
tell these young women they will never
be as good as the men i actually took
issue with that back then saying like
if you may believe that but don't
discourage people tell them to strive to
be the best
and and to view that as competition to
be better but when you look
at you mentioned skiing i'm thinking
skateboarding
there's no question you watch men's you
know x games skateboarding
and you'll notice a very obvious
difference between the male and the
female skateboarding
but actually uh i actually took some
basic first aid training i've actually
done hostile environment training so i
got a
bit more extensive and when i was
younger and trying to learn some of the
basics of first aid because i'm i'm i'm
getting you know i skate it all the time
and my mom feels like it's important you
should learn some stuff google it and
you know i did
i learned some things about sports women
are more likely to suffer knee and ankle
injuries skateboarding than men yeah but
because of something called the q
angle which is the hip the wide hips of
females
means that their femurs are at a wider
angle than men's
which means they're more prone to joint
injury than a man and the same thing in
the military when you start talking
about
going for a 12-mile ruck march and
you've got 60 pounds on your back
and really in combat you're carrying a
whole lot more but you
get this you see the sustainment of
those injuries because there is a
physiological
difference now coming back to what your
questions say ian i want the best
possible person to be out there as a
leader
but the thing is that you've got to be
able to lead and accomplish the exact
same tasks that you're asking
your troops to be able to do when i was
in combat
i was right up there hooking and jabbing
with my guys if there was a x percentage
of my unit that was dedicated to a
combat operation
i was out there okay and and so that's
the thing
that has to happen you know combat is
not
about social engineering combat is not
about equity
combat is about you against another
person
and killing that person that you know
that that's that's what war is war is
hell
that's what william tecumseh sherman
said and as a matter of fact it was a
nathan bedford
forest and hopefully no one gets upset
because i'm quoting a confederate
general
but nathan bedford forrest is war is
about fighting
and fighting is about killing that's the
bottom line
it's not a computer game where you're
sitting back and you got a bunch of
drones or whatever
the bottom line is someone has to be on
the ground
and point something at somebody else and
eliminate them
and that's what we need to be thinking
about because that's what the national
security united states of america is all
about now i'll say something that will
probably offend a lot of the left where
i'm actually trying to make a point in
favor of women in the military is that
there's that saying we heard it recently
was it um soldiers march on their
bellies
something that affects yeah that you
need to keep a a military
uh well regulated in terms of their
equipment not in terms of law
you need to keep them well fed and like
a well-oiled machine
when tucker carlson made these comments
about you know flight suits for pregnant
women
uh i disagree with them i think that you
know
a lot of these jobs and i was explaining
is this explained to me a lot of people
there's a lot of logistics a lot of
administrative work look i can't fly a
fighter jet and they're a female fighter
pies
i can't fly a helicopter and there are a
lot of female attack helicopter pilots
i was just a dumbo paratrooper that
jumped out airplanes and i was
an artillery officer and what i am
saying is that yes
there are positions and duties out there
that people can serve
in but there are still standards that
say
your body in your physiology will only
allow you to do
x and so if we want to start having
women as navy seals if we want to have
women's past
just pass the same doggone test that
everybody else is
absolutely the and and
don't have what we have seen where all
of a sudden there's a
altering of rules there's the you know
adding of more chances and opportunities
to get out there and try to accomplish
something because a lot of the guys
don't get that
i want to give you my thoughts on the on
the transgenders uh uh
serving the military issue you know you
mentioned that the dsm-5 i think says
it's a it's a mental condition
and that's actually been uh staunchly
advocated for by many trans individuals
because it grants them access to
medication but
i digress i i there's a lot of people
who say have diabetes the
legitimate question is would that would
diabetes prohibit you from enlisting or
serving
absolutely it would epilepsy all these
things
i mean you know heart murmurs
sleep apnea i had one of my captains
in iraq you know hats but is that just
combat could you
could you run an administrative role
could you yeah drive a vehicle no
but but you may be but again what are
you doing
you're creating two separate classes i
mean but what what
let's be fair though you can't the navy
seals are the best of the best yeah but
you cannot yell but you cannot create
two separate classes where we say
okay you can go be in the fat boy unit
yeah see
no no i'm serious you laugh but but let
me tell you how brutal it is
in the united states military where the
military i grew up in you the fat boy
that falls out of run oh man you're
gonna hear it
but you become the repti boy soon don't
you you better yeah
if you want to stay in yeah so what
happened with you they'll
i'm sorry they'll throw the captain with
you're overweight and well if you enlist
okay you're going to have to meet height
weight standards before you can ship out
the basic training interesting and even
when you go to basic training you're
still going to be monitored you still
have to make those height and weight
standards
okay and and again you know on active
duty you got to continue to have your
height and weight test and your body fat
examination if you don't make it then
you go i don't care what level that you
rise to now what happened to the captain
in iraq
i had to send him back home oh jesus out
of the comments was it like something
and and you you don't know how hurtful
it was
for me as his battalion commander to
look at this kid who had
tears in his eyes begging me not to send
him back
begging me telling me that he he'll make
it through even though he can't get
sleep and everything
but i was he was he overweight no he
wasn't overweight but he had sleep apnea
and i was seeing how
it was affecting his duties because he
couldn't get sleep
yeah that's true and and i couldn't have
him go out there
and the next thing you know he's a
detriment not just to himself
but to someone else and i had to tell
him i got to send you back home
so you need the best of the best of the
best the cream of the crop top at the
top
well i mean you got you got tip of the
spear you got seals delta force or
whatever
and then you got you know your everyday
soldier sailor every marine but
you've got to still have maintain
certain standards through
throughout that strata did the captain
get honorably discharged or did he just
of course he got honorably discharged
but he didn't get moved to a civilian
or like a non-combat role he was just
actually discharged from the military
yeah he he ended up being discharged in
military because it wasn't treatable
but he couldn't be in that machine but
he could be in the combat zone and and
when you talk about what tucker
was was bringing up about the pregnant
soldiers in 1995 and i was stationed in
korea
i was up on dmz and it was called area
one and in area one
before females got you know shipped up
there they had to take a pregnancy test
because why you could not be sending to
area one and with pregnancy tests
because we were the tip of the spear you
you were you were in a deployed
zone now guess what what happened
sometimes you know little boy soldiers a
little girl soldiers they do little
things you know
and the next thing you know you get a
pregnant female soldier but you know
what the army would not allow us to do
we couldn't redeploy that soldier back
even though now that she's pregnant
she's non-deployable she cannot wear
a gas mask because that can affect her
she cannot so she has to stay
up in area one for x amount of time and
then i think in the fifth or sixth month
then you could you know what would the
chinese do
in that situation chinese i don't think
uh deal with that do they even have
female soldiers
i think they do have female soldiers but
i don't think they're in their front
line troops yeah i think they're they're
much more
bigoted i think the left would call them
well as a matter of fact i read an
article recent where the chinese were
talking about they need to have
uh non-feminization training for males
yeah the masculinity training i mean
they are looking at what is happening
in in the west and they're saying we
don't want that
yeah you know what that you know the
advantage they have over us
is actually the biggest detriment that
their people suffer is the
authoritarianism
absolutely it's an advantage for to a
point to a point right
i had a conversation with my anarchist
friend of mine years ago where i said
that it is much more efficient in many
ways an authoritarian regime
because they snap their fingers and they
impose their will where we deal with
bureaucracy
granted it's a despicable way to live
but you know atrocities and you and i
were talking about this before we came
on air
this is the downfall of an authoritarian
regime
it restrains and restricts creativity
yep and we saw that
you know that was one of the things
about our military as opposed to the
soviet
model style is that our young troops
could make a decision our junk troops
were trained when you think about
you know all of the wars you know it's a
sergeant here's a corporal there that is
able to do something
whereby when you have that authoritative
system and that was the big problem we
had in afghanistan
in training their army was that even if
they were in a firefight with the
taliban
they wouldn't take an action i said what
are you doing well i have to wait for
the call from my commander to do
something
i said that's they're shooting at you
okay taking action yeah and that's that
was something that they had to learn but
they grew up under that soviet mentality
so
that's happening now it is happening now
so an authoritarian regime
like what you see taking place here what
is telling you what you can wear
what you can eat what you can think what
you can drive
it may sound again free does not equal
freedom
i i've hired people and uh i'll tell you
the story
i'll give a story from a buddy of mine
he started a company he was doing social
media management
he made some posts on the internet
looking for some you know people to help
me run these these social media websites
for clients
must have a college degree well the
people with college degree with college
degrees have salary requirements so he
hired him
he said that he would get his phone be
ringing off the hook from people with
problems hey i got a problem
they posted this hey i got a problem the
company wants this what do i do what do
i do what do i do eventually said if you
can't do the job then i need to find
someone else so he fires him
puts another post up needs needs
somebody who knows social media can
can run marketing must have a college
degree what is what happens
same thing phone call after phone call
after phone call well now he's out of
money
he spent a bunch of money training these
people he wasn't getting output so he
just said
looking for people who know social media
10 bucks an hour
he gets a couple people who had moved
from middle america to california to
find
their dream and acting and he says he
says here's the job go for it
not a single phone call now he's worried
uh oh
they something must be going wrong
because they're not telling me anything
he comes back everything okay it's all a
good bus and he was like no problems no
problems well there was this one thing
from one of these restaurants but we
took care of it
and so what he said was these young
people that moved
from the middle of the country to
california of their own volition with no
college with no education
took the initiative it wasn't the
college degree it was that they
knew they were confident in themselves
to figure out and solve this problem
whereas the people who went to college
were the people who did what they were
told by their parents
and now they're you know 24 with no
experience in the real world and they're
panicking because they don't have to
solve these problems and they're asking
you to solve it for them why
the kids who went to college would
always go to their professor or their
teacher and say what do i do now yeah
and so what i see happening in this
country is a lot of that from college
people who are indoctrinated into saying
but not even the college level
it's happening down in high schools and
middle schools and this is one of the
things i don't like about this
standardized testing
because what standardized testing is
doing is is creating robotic thinking
you know you we have to teach you to be
able to pass a test we're not teaching
you
to have critical thinking skills to be
an independent thinker
and then of course we you know you need
to go to college and if we make college
free then everyone goes to college and
then what happens
to the productivity of people that's
exactly what happens
one of the things that i would always
talk about when i was in the military i
want a person i want a soldier
that's a fire and forget weapon system
that's what you're talking about
it's a fire and forget weapon system so
it's not same as when you
take that that uh that pistol or that
rifle you pull the trigger
as long as you have aimed it in the
right place the bullet is going to hit
the target
and so that's the type of people that we
should be trying to develop
or fire and forget weapon system
individuals that
understand critical thinking that
understand independent thought
and we're rewarding them for being
independent thinkers
but what progressivism socialism statism
communism
marxism whatever you want to call it
what it is creating is a collective
group think you know when i came in here
you had star trek the next generation
love it star trek the next generation
remember the borg
oh yeah okay what was the board the
board was a collective body
no individuality whatsoever what did the
borg say resistance
is futile you will you are what what is
it
you will similarly simulate you know
your technology and your culture will be
assimilated
resistance and that's exactly what we
see happening
young people is that you have this
collective mentality and mindset that
does not want you to be a fire and
forget weapons system
it wants you to be part of a council
culture it wants you to be part of a
social justice
warrior you know clan or whatever you
know
you've got to be able to go out and
think and do and and be able to survive
on your own
instead of sitting around for the
authoritarians
to say that we're going to give you some
free health care we're going to give you
some free college education what's fire
forget
that's like you shoot and you just you
just accept it's done
that's exactly what he said hiring
someone that you tell them here's your
task and purpose
and they got it all right they don't
come back they don't come back and keep
bugging you
you ever read the same message to garcia
it's a little short pamphlet read the
the little message to garcia there was a
a gentleman by the name
the gentleman in the military that was
chosen to to deliver a message to a
a cuban fighter named garcia where's
garcia
you just got to find him what does
garcia look like you'll figure it out
and the guy took the message and he
found garcia and you know that's what we
want and you know
i've experienced when i hire i've hired
college grads
i've been told you have to tell me what
to do no joke no joke i hired someone
once
and they were like what do i i hired
them for a specific job administrative
role
and then i remember one day one day they
came to me and said i don't know how to
do this what am i supposed to do and i
was like if i knew how to do it i would
not have hired
you to do it so listen you've got all
the time in the world figure it out
reasonably i expect you to figure it out
quickly but i understand
this like you go to school for certain
things i understand you can learn
this specific program was not something
you learned in college but you can spend
the day figuring out the software they
couldn't do it
yeah they just said just tell me how to
do it i don't know how to do it either
and and that's why you know back when i
was growing up the old folks down south
they used to say that boy got a whole
lot of book learning he ain't got no
common sense
and that's what they were talking about
the difference between knowledge and
wisdom absolutely
absolutely and so if there's a threat
that i see
for us as a country is getting back to
that sense of rugged
individualism and getting back to that
sense of
i can and not sitting around and waiting
for someone to tell me
what you know what to do because that
collective mentality
will always destroy you i feel like we
need like an emergency
to whip people into that frenzy of do it
well that's why you all are here yeah
that's why y'all are here and that's
what y'all are doing that's what y'all
are professing that's why i was
look i am so humble that you guys would
you know
ask me to come up with a gun look look
this is this is awesome because
you know again this is that logan's run
moment
when you find the old guy out there in
the sanctuary and you bring it back to
the to the young city
and they impart all of this wisdom tell
you man i want to start a new political
movement
party whatever i don't care about party
politics but i want to involve the
brightest minds
do a popular win like it's just
popularity contest at this point make
tim president i'll be the vice president
never going to be a president or a
politician i don't maybe we don't need a
president
a better system but this is the movement
that you all created because
you are a bright and shiny light like it
says in the bible in matthew chapter
five you're the shining city that sits
upon a hill
you're you're that you're that light
that sits on the lampstand
that you cannot put a cover over and you
guys have got to continue to get this
message out here
because that's my concern remember what
i said there was once upon a time when i
could sit down with my parents
and watch the grammys i can't do that
there's no way that i my daughters are
27-24
was no way i would have said that that
would have been really awkward it was
just totally awkward from cardi b
totally awkward i can't sit down and
watch i don't even
some of these super bowl uh halftime
shows i don't watch it with them
yeah i couldn't i couldn't watch it
alone well so here's here's the
important to watch
the grammys is a really good uh uh i
mean issue to bring up in that
our culture is completely fragmented and
divided you know you're you're here
saying
this is the message we got the message
out and i and i think about some of the
things that we've talked about in terms
of the armed forces and
especially in terms of the transgender
issue and i mean those are extremely
divisive topics
where you you even challenge some of
these orthodoxies on the left
and they get violent there are certain
things sure where we've seen people on
the board
no other get violent no answer that's
right yeah
my dad used to say a hit dog will holler
yep yeah i think it's the uh
when people can't find a logical course
of action
they they become angry right but if
you're giving it the spurs and it has
a place to go it's not going to scream
it's just going to go but my concern is
when you look to the grammys when you
look to the establishment the the major
marketing companies the social media
companies
they're the borg they're the ones who
are saying assimilate or else
yeah and and many of these people that
we used to see on youtube we did we did
a members only segment the other day
about this
the anti-sjw was we called them some of
them have just capitulated and given in
and now they won't necessarily
agree with everything from the look
establishment but they're certainly no
longer critical of the establishment
they like shifted gears
and now they go for soft targets because
they're scared they're scared the
machine will come for them will destroy
them
if if we don't have people who are
willing to stand up and be on the front
line
there are more of us than there are them
and i truly believe that
and and one thing that my mom taught me
was that a man must stand for something
or else he'll fall for anything
and so to those people that are running
away from their
you know fundamental principles and
values you know you can never
acquiesce compromise appease or
negotiate enough
with the the far left with with these
the the
the woke council culture there's there's
nothing that you can give to them
which will ever satiate their appetite
for more control and more power
so at some point in time you're gonna
have to make a stand
at some point in time you're gonna have
to say enough i mean
pepe le pew peter gonzales joe biden
i don't get it no no joe biden is a
bigger abuser than pepe le pew was
like you can see the videos of joe biden
grabbing the women what's your name
uh tara reid i mean that's what and
still these
tables and these stories were buried and
pepe le pew is the offensive thing
but cardi b is not listen listen pepe le
pew
was prancing around saying mon sherry or
whatever
no but look if you want to criticize old
art or old cultural tropes
i got no problem with that there are a
lot of things from the 20s we don't we
don't show these days
30s 40s 50s that that's fine by me but
don't come out with this cardb stuff
which again i also honestly don't care
about i won't watch it you want to do
that you can do it i'll be somewhere
else
yeah but listen how are you going to
show that and then claim pepe le pew is
the more
you know the bad thing i don't know
that's a good question
well you know what i think it's going to
come from when you look at comedians out
there like
jerry seinfeld and others that are
saying that this is going too far i mean
mel brooks and and and the movie blazing
saddles
you couldn't show blazing saddles that
was the first r-rated movie i was
allowed to watch
i wasn't going to watch anything i mean
but my dad let me watch that one yeah
because it was so good
it was just hilarious what a good i mean
how long how long until quentin
tarantino gets
gets banned i mean come on that dude
uses racial slurs every chance he gets
it's it's in his movies well in the
context it depends on if he bows down to
the guys
or the left i don't think he will well
no i don't like it but maybe a lot of
them do a lot of them do
so but but think about it sarah
silverman has come out and said this is
too much
well bill maher yeah bill maher has come
out and you started listening to some of
the things that he's saying
you know it's cool i like i i like bill
maher um i think he's got trump
derangement syndrome
and and he spent he's too wrapped up in
you
let me stop there it's the blue pill and
the red pill people think red pill means
you're a republican it doesn't it means
you've recognized the narrative from the
media is you know often
complete bs bill maher still believes
too much of it
but it's like he's in that you know
blue-pilled room looking out the window
and kind of seeing
the freedom and recognizing the problem
but he doesn't break through it takes
him a long time
yeah and eventually he will come around
because
again there is no trump boogeyman out
there
and the further further they get away
from the trump boogeyman
all of a sudden they're going to reach
out and see this ain't working well
they're trying to do tucker now
brian he's like tucker is the new trump
yeah yeah all right let's uh let's go to
super chats because we've got a lot of
people who are got a ton of questions
for you and a lot of people really seem
to love you a lot
so if you haven't already smash that
like button it really does help
and you may notice that we have the it's
it's the diamond hands gorilla t-shirt
where he's wearing a suit he says i'm a
girl he's got money in his hand
sunglasses and he's smoking this is
our homage to the gamestop stocks
crowd where they have that meme about
the gorillas from planet of the apes and
so we turned our shirt into that one
because we thought it was funny
you can get that and if you go to
timcast.com click the shop button
and we're also going to have a really
awesome exclusive members only segment
later today
uh at around 11 or so at timecast.com
but let's read some of these super chats
and if you really do like the podcast
share it leave us a good review all that
good stuff
we got this from the civic nationalist
he says lieutenant colonel allen
thank you for your service to your
country and continuing to serve your
country
from two para pte to the yanks
your enemy of your country is never
going to stop what are you going to do
to stop it
well you know without a doubt we're
going to continue to fight them uh
on this ideological battlefield and i
think that being on a show like this and
bringing out these thoughts perspectives
and insights everything that i have in
my head
imparting that wisdom so that you can
empower people to be able to fight in
their own respective spaces and in their
communities and what have you so
that's it's all about leading by example
and i think if
folks can see the courage that i display
to stand up to the uh to the left
then they will be inspired to be
courageous as well we have one just a
general compliment raymond fields says
you made my night by having one of my
favorite people on
i love allen west oh thank you very much
there you go
and then we have ty uh tyler bachmann
thank you tim cast irl crew your show
helped keep my mind off of a recent
breakup this is my new favorite podcast
well if you really do like it smash the
like button share it all that good stuff
really appreciate it keegan devlin says
thank you for this guest after last
night's show
last uh after last night's show this is
the hero we need
look man i i genuinely respect raka for
coming on because
uh for those that don't know a lot of
people weren't weren't thrilled with
that show didn't like it didn't want to
hear what had to say but we have to have
hard conversations
a lot of people really like you uh alan
west and your ideas and opinions
so they definitely here are here for it
but i think it's very important to
listen to people you don't like
and i i do it often i pull up
progressives and people i disagree with
i follow them on twitter
i try to make sure i understand what
they're thinking because sometimes they
have good ideas
and it's important to find that
commonality if we're going to build a
better future as americans
it's also important to understand where
we disagree so i understand their
arguments
accurately i think a lot of people on
the right like
me because i'm trying to be honest and
honestly represent people of all
different stripes and that means
i follow a bunch of progressives i
follow a bunch of conservatives and i
think we gotta we gotta you know have
those conversations well i will tell
folks uh if if i could recommend
several books to read you've got to read
saul olenski's rules for radicals
definitely you have got to read karl
marx communist manifesto
you've got to read frederick basia the
law and you've got to read alexis the
toefl democracy in america
so i would say read those four books
because you've got to understand who you
are what you believe in
you got to understand the other side who
they are and what they believe in that's
right
joshua brewer says could you ask colonel
west in what era he thinks the democrats
were the worst
civil war new deal jim crow and
segregation or this new form of
destruction which is all three of the
others combined i think it's the new era
that has started since lyndon baines
johnson and the great society programs
because what you have seen happen when
even though i was born in a blacks only
hospital
almost 77 percent of black kids have
mommy and daddy in the home today is
only 24
so i think that this modern post
post-modern liberalism progressivism
socialism
of the democratic party is far worse is
it accurate to refer to you as colonel
or lieutenant
is it lieutenant colonel you can call me
you can call me colonel as long as
there's not a full colonel around
they'll take offense today
but yeah but you can just be careful
chairman is that does that sound weird
that's funny you know you're chairman
i'm not you know
servant is the best one husband is the
best
father is the best one and grandpa come
mate
congratulations there you go
congratulations yeah
uh erica baum with just wow this is a
really uh
amazing compliment tim you filled
rogan's youtube void this guest is legit
and i'm so happy to see mr west here
right now clap clap much respect
thank you i mean people really love
allen west wow
holy s it's colonel west god bless you
sir but on the fence with enlisting in
the national guard
as e4 with my degree however now biden
thoughts advice
well it depends on what state that
you're in because first and foremost
you're going to be serving that state
and so you know regardless of who's in
the white house serving your country is
a great thing
you know when when i was in the military
i did eight years under bill clinton
was it easy absolutely not but
i was still serving my country and
that's the most important thing and the
great thing about our men and women who
serve
they don't take a note to a political
party they don't take a note to a person
they took an
oath to the constitution of the united
states of america on 31 july 1982
i said i alan bernard with west will
support and defend the constitution
of the united states of america against
all enemies foreign and domestic
that i'll bear true faith and allegiance
to the same that i take this
obligation freely without any purpose of
invasion of mental reservation so help
me god
the great thing about that oath my dad
took that oath
as a soldier in world war ii my older
brother took that oath as a marine who
served in vietnam i took that oath
and my nephew took that oath and now
he's a lieutenant colonel
in the united states so there is nothing
greater
than saying those words and meaning it
and serving this great nation
and that's what i fear because even
police have a have a similar
uh oh to defend the constitution too
many people don't really mean it
that that worries me if we ever get to
the point as a nation
where we're not raising up the next
generation of men
and women who sincerely want to serve
this country who sincerely as abraham
lincoln said not too far away
from here gettysburg are willing to make
the last full measure of devotion
so that we can give them the increased
amount of devotion if we ever get to the
point where we're not raising that next
generation
then i'm worried about america but i
still see the young man such as that one
right there
what do you think about the grand
commander supreme commander
commander-in-chief
being left up to a popularity contest i
am very concerned because
once upon a time uh you could not be the
president of the united states of
america if you had not said those words
that i said and served in uniform
as a matter of fact uh back in the mid
night to late 1970s uh i think it was
close to
80 percent 75 to 80 percent of the
people who serve in the house and senate
has served in the uniform
now that number's like 18 wow and if you
think that there's a difference
there is a difference because there's
something about willing to lay your life
down
for something and then you get the
opportunity like i did to go and serve
the country and still
defend and honor that oath but you do it
in a suit and tie you do it in one of
those institutions that you swore to
defend
we got to get back to that we got to get
back to citizen legislatures and
servants
have you ever watched or read starship
troopers of course
casper van dien there you go service
guarantees citizenship service
guarantees citizenship
it's interesting that they called that
idea fascistic this idea that you would
earn your your right to
you know vote and participate in civics
by agreeing to serve your society
i don't think is fascistic at all i
don't think it's fascistic at all and i
don't think it's a far-fetched theme
i think that when you look at really you
want to talk about
the one percenters it's the people that
have served
this country in uniform less than one
percent
i think it's like maybe point six
percent have done a full
20-year career wow to the united states
of america
that are alive today that's your real
one percenters
and i would just challenge any young man
woman to be a part of that
real elite group of people i i just see
these powerful interests manipulating
those good people
you know i i have uh like i mentioned i
lived just off of fort eustis i had a
lot of friends who
you know my brother obviously and um my
sister married in i was in fort carson
i met a lot of really awesome people
brave people i've met a lot of humble
people you know
particularly in newport news who tell me
they don't consider it like you know a
lot of people like you're a hero for
serving and they're like oh come on you
know it's a job i'm i'm right i
understand
but they're they're humble they're
regular people and they are willing to
take greater risks and
you know especially those who fight in
combat but then i see this big machine
this political elite machine of people
who are millionaires who don't serve
who don't care and they manipulate the
good men and women in uniform and that's
the thing
and is that if we want to see a
difference in our country
there has to be a difference in us as
the voting electorate so that we don't
see it as a popularity contest we are
looking for servants we're looking for
leaders
we're looking for the person that we
believe would lay down their life for
this country
all right let's read some more we got
urban lagoon says hey tim been a fan
since forever
love alan west also i served four years
in the army
also from northeast ohio ian rust belt
flyovers for the win
can i get a shout out for my first skate
edit bad hair
days and it's d-a-z on my channel you
got it buddy
all right we got this uh joe a says i
wonder how colonel west
views the purge of radicals in the
military that is horrible
i am so concerned i am so concerned
about this
because we are instituting the policy of
political officers in our military
we're putting commissars in our military
and so when we start to have people
that are talking about purging and
looking through social media accounts
of men and women in uniform but only for
conservative sites right
that's cancelled culture you're
politicizing our military
and and that is a very very dangerous
path to go down because our military
serves our constitution they serve this
country
they don't serve a political party and i
don't want to see us to have some type
of soviet-style
military so well that's that's that's
what i worry about
that's what they're trying to implement
in some of these stories they said that
people who had like posted images of the
gadsden flag on facebook
were getting pulled from dc there is a
there is a
a chaplain at fort hood texas
who on his own personal facebook account
posted that he did not agree with the uh
gender dysphoria of transgenders you
know openly serving in the military
he was brought up in an investigation
wow
on his own personally now he's a
chaplain now he that's his freedom of
religion freedom of speech and what have
you
and now they're investigating the
chaplain so i'm very concerned about the
politicization of our military
i think we they want to create a
monoculture of course
they want to get rid of anyone who
challenges their orthodoxy
it's the borg right resistance
is futile that's what they want you to
believe that resistance is futile and
you will assimilate
but we don't have to so long as we keep
having these conversations
we got a chat here from christopher
mccann he says texas resident and
conservative
thank you lieutenant colonel west for
your service to the country how can i
get involved in state
politics particularly ousting clay
jenkins from his dallas county judge
position
hey i'm all about that because i live in
dallas county too he says i want to get
involved in the campaign against him but
don't know how
okay i will tell you to please go to the
republican party of texas website
and one of the things you can
immediately do is to go to the drop down
tab for legislative priorities
and start getting involved in our
legislative priorities but also the
dallas county republican party
let's start looking at our local level
elections that will happen on may
the first city council school board
county clerk county commission those are
very important
clay jenkins is not up in this election
cycle but in two years he will be and we
need to get it rid of clay jenkins you
want to talk about a despotic
ruler in dallas county clay jenkins is
an example
alexander olsen says i propose the new
name for sjw
social justice or cancel culture be hate
machine
cult culture cultist all it does is
deconstruct
and demonize and destroy the result is
division deprivation despair and death
down with the hate machine cult i agree
i do i'm all about individual freedoms
liberty respect and that includes people
of all different backgrounds i think
people deserve equality under the law
but i just think it's the
authoritarianism
like i i like i i like a lot of true
social justice
only need be called justice just justice
you don't have to
you don't have to qualify justice right
and just make sure that it is equally
administered all across the board they
use they say climate justice
social justice housing justice and
really it's just
uh it's just a manipulation
to make you think you're fighting the
good fight the the economic crisis of
2008 came because of housing justice
when jimmy carter in 1978 created the uh
uh the commercial reinvestment act which
basically said everyone has a right to
own a home and government got involved
in the
you know private mortgage industry 30
years later you had that economic
meltdown
subprime mortgages all of that stuff in
reference to the guns uh
the gun uh conversation nick sheamus
says make nicks available to the public
that's the nics background check
does that make sense do you think what
do you think people could use it and
then if they want to do a private
transfer they could access it
as long as there's some second check you
know just the same as when you go to buy
a firearm there's always a second check
of that 4473 and one of the problems
that i think that we have out there is
a lack of of review of
of that nick system the the shooter down
in sutherland springs
texas who went in and shot the church up
their first baptist sutherland springs
he should not have been able to purchase
a firearm
he was a he was a felon he was
disarmedly discharged from the united
states air force
but yet he did not properly answer on
his 4473.
he was not caught and he was able to
purchase a weapon so it is not
us the legal law-abiding system citizens
it's the system out there that we have
in place that needs to be corrected and
fixed yeah
g perez says don't always agree but
great show
to uh lieutenant colonel west retired
deep strike and abn
troop here god bless yes deep strike
what do you think about the loss of
judeo-christian ideals in the u.s
i think that this is a very big concern
that's why h.r 5
is is very threatening to that very
first liberty that you have
there's a reason why the founding
fathers put the freedom of religion and
the free exercise
thereof is your very first right in your
bill of rights
because they saw what happened in
england when the head of state made
himself the head of religion
head of church and that's what thomas
jefferson talked about in that letter to
the danbury baptist convention about
separation of church and state
it was not to have so much of that
authoritarian power concentrated in one
person
that said that here are the laws and
here is religion as well
you want to make sure that they stay
separated so it is
so important that the religion of the
left
it does not supersede our
judeo-christian faith heritage
you know uh i i grew up catholic for a
few years
and uh then went to public school kind
of lost a lot of that but
i i know a bit i know i knew enough that
when i looked up things like
blackstone's formulation yeah i
understood the root being the story of
sodom and gomorrah and
if there's about one righteous person
it's interesting to me because we talked
about this i think it was with
um who did we talk about this it was one
of our catholic guests sheamus
no it wasn't it might have been sheamus
or drew that may have been both actually
this idea that even though many liberals
don't understand this
like i'm talking about 90s and 2000
liberals they like to say like bill
maher's a good example
like religion doesn't make me a moral
person but he was
raised in a society that has for a long
time
held judeo-christian values and while i
think it's fair to say you might be
secularists you may be atheist i think
it's important to realize that people
they often don't understand this i know
this because i've actually looked into
what are one of the ideals that we hold
as a liberal society blackstone's
formulation
innocent until proven guilty the right
to a trial by jury of your peers
things like that it is rooted very much
so in
these values commandments what we've
basically done yeah
is we've we've come from an age where we
had a bunch of bad ideas
but some good ideas we kept those good
ideas got rid of some of those bad ideas
and every generation we've been keeping
the good ideas now it feels like we're
entering this period where
we're starting to build up bad ideas and
get rid of the good ideas yeah that's
without disagreeing
and and it even talks about that in the
bible when
you will call bad good and you will call
good bad
and i think that we're entering into
that phase and yeah
you know when you hear people say that
there's no objective truth
uh i kind of disagree with you i mean
two plus two does equal four
well they're interesting five now you
saw that math is not racist
you you've seen them saying well i know
i know that's the most insane thing but
i don't want that person to build a
bridge
what they're doing is they've actually
argued two plus two
sometimes equals five and then they add
a bunch of qualifiers that aren't a part
of the equation
that's common core math well so one of
the things they've said is what if it's
2.9
plus 2.9 it's like well then that's a
different equation that's 5.8
exactly and you can round it up to six
i mean if you want a whole number
they're trying to argue that there could
be hidden decimals and that if you're
thinking critically the answer could be
different
but the problem is you're giving a
straight forward you know i would tell
this to people
look there's a window in front of me
what happens if i take this rock and i
throw at the window
when it's gonna break very likely the
window's gonna break we can recognize
maybe sometimes it doesn't but come on
you throw a rock out of the window
window breaks
well again it's bulletproof again that
comes back to what the old folks used to
say down south that boy got a lot of
book learning he ain't got no common
sense i make the argument that one plus
one equals two
but in base two mathematics and binary
one plus one equals one
zero because there's only two decimals
there's a zero and a one in binary and
that's five
no two you would basically say one plus
one in binary and then ask them for the
answer you would say
well if you don't if you just ask the
question what's one plus one and you
don't tell them what base math they're
in
it could be one zero it could be two but
it's the same
quantity right so here's it looks
they're looking at it in a different way
the issue is they're literally arguing
that you have two apples and two apples
you put them together
and an apple appears out of nowhere that
argument's nonsense they're arguing that
language defines our ideas and they're
trying to deconstruct
math that's true though well the
language doesn't find ideas because if
you and i are looking at a six from here
i'm going to say it's a nine you're
going to say
six but the idea is we can call it
one or we can call it blorb it
represents the same value
simply because language may be different
doesn't change the fact that there's a
certain value
and they're trying to argue that there
could be hidden values and equations
that aren't a part of the equation but i
don't i don't want to rehash two
there are four people in this room
that's a good point
there are four lights uh you know that
reference yeah there are four lights no
next generation okay this picard was
captured by the cardassians they were
torturing him
oh man demanding he's a trekkie he is
he's all the way
yeah so they were demanding he's he's
torturing him there are four lights and
he was how many lights are there
and he says therefore no there are five
and piccard refuses to say like there
are four lights it's like 1984. yeah
they were trying to force them to do it
and we're living in 1984.
definitely all right we got student of
history says with all due respect to
both of you sizing each other up on 2a
i must ask where do y'all stand uh stand
scale from one to abram's mbt me
personally i read
that shall not be infringed part of part
and go yup
seems legit although i also recognize a
the well-regulated militia
i cannot fit an abrams battle tank in my
garage
i would i would love to but i cannot fit
it and plus it's a it's a cruise serve
and right now
uh i have an empty nest so it's only my
wife and myself and i don't think she
could drive it and she definitely
couldn't be the gunner can you legally
own it
no you don't think so no i don't think
so now if you're a museum
and if you have some now yes you could
you could purchase something
like a a tank or what have you and then
there's some still restrictions on what
you could do
because there's some people here locally
i know that have a museum they have m60
tanks oh we
there's a guy who drives around not too
far from here with a world war
ii jeep with a full auto 50 bmg
on it and he doesn't keep it armed
doesn't keep ammo with him or anything
but he lets people come up and just
shoot down stuff like that sure and i'm
sure he's got a special permit for you
there's an interesting argument here in
that during during the the revolutionary
era when they were coming up with these
ideas
people owned private warships yeah
they're volunteers
exactly exactly so i mean they
understood that concept yeah people had
these things
yeah what's the difference today well uh
i don't know i don't know i know i don't
know if we
you know you can legally own a tank i'm
trying to think you know can
can a person you know have a little
patrol boat
i guess they probably could you can
legally own a tank
my understanding is you just can't have
an operational artillery but you can
have guns mounted on it and things like
that and they're
yeah you can't you can't go and load it
up with any sabo rounds okay you can't
have a 128 millimeter stable round
but yeah you could have yeah i know let
me tell you 30 years ago
30 years ago right now operation does
shield desert storm
and let me tell you something there is
nothing prettier than seeing
an m1a1 abrams battle tank
take out a t-72 at like
a mile away wow i mean it's just a
beautiful scene that's physics man
isaac newton was made the british empire
take over the world because of physics
yep yeah people absolutely love you man
i mean west
the the the hurricane says possibly the
best episode ever
and yes i'm considering alex and michael
in this decision
oh michael oh he's going to be upset now
no probably not
and then uh joey ward says the tim best
interview i've ever seen and i listen
every day
well you know we get we we were graced
with the the presence of
an honor to be here i mean we're
grateful that you're here as well
all right here we go dj madeiro says to
lieutenant colonel west from bend oregon
quote there are two sides to every issue
one side is right and the other side is
wrong
but the middle is always evil ein rand
quote
ps navy veteran my grandfather was a u.s
marine on
wake island in world war ii the world
wonders well you know one of the things
and it's funny i mean lydia and i were
discussing this
and the bible in revelation says you're
either hot or you're cold if you look
warm i'll spew you from my mouth but
also
my dad taught me this my dad was such an
uh an insightful man
he said son the only thing in the middle
of the road is road kill
and that's why well you're talking to me
right now because i'm the guy on the
fence they always complain about
you you're gonna be roadkill maybe make
a decision but i i think a lot of people
well i'll tell you this though a lot of
people are like tim's on the fence and
the reality is i'm not really on the
fence on the issues of freedom liberty
constitutionalists if you tell me you're
constitutionless you're not in the
middle of the road right
there are certain issues i am definitely
on the middle road you know what i mean
they call me the milk toast defense
sitter as a joke
but i think that's more to do with often
i'm trying to explore ideas and not
push my own on other people and i i
respect you so much for that
and that's one of the things that you
know i like to come on to shows where
we can have that intellectual discourse
in exchange because
again you know you only get stronger
if you swim against the current right
otherwise you're just loafing on an
inner tube going downstream yeah
absolutely i mean that
that's i mean it's easy to go i'm scuba
diving it's easy to go scuba dive and do
drift diving you don't have to kick you
have to do anything let the carrot just
carry fun though right
it's fun because you don't have to exert
any energy but you don't get any
stronger
yeah all right we got lka zaruto says
alan
i am a native texan millennial
conservative woman and attorney
how can i get more involved in public
policy in texas and help keep our state
from going insane
if i was in the military i would not
want a job i'm not physically ready for
well once again uh you have some great
organizations there you got texas public
policy foundation
uh conservative you know center right or
group and
again follow us at the republican party
of texas go to our legislative
priorities because we are in our 87th
legislative session which will end
at the end of may and drop down the
digital playbook that we have created
for our eight priorities
and look and see how you can contact
your state house member state senator
and get engaged in that process and uh
you know i always tell
young millennials in texas that william
barrett travis the man who commanded the
alamo for 20
for 13 days was only 26 years of age
yeah
people don't realize you know thomas
jefferson wasn't he like 26 or whatever
man wrote the declaration of
independence incredible
yeah see that's what we that's what this
show is doing
this show is making sure that we have
that next generation of travis
and jefferson's and others and i'm going
to restate what i said like the other
day but
we got to have that generation of people
who are willing to get on a boat for
three months
sailing you know with the wind then
crashing on the shore of some
foreign land just with nothing but trees
and then saying gotta get started and
just build from nothing
and that's a fire and forget weapon
system yeah that's the person that's not
going to land and say
what do i do who's going to feed me
better photography secret swim buddy
that's america that's rugged
individualism also to write a
constitution
if it's wrong it's wrong wow but but
think about it
that's it yeah that's the declaration
and the concept there's this thing
called the manila principles have you
heard of them it's a digital
constitution for the internet age it's
just six
parts of like you know shall not be
infringed and things and i don't know
i'm off the top of my head i probably
should
but you know things like that because we
need to add to this document for this
this digital age people need to realize
how brilliant the structure of govern
the united states was
like i i thought i remember when i was a
kid and i was learning about the
branches of government
and i'm like so they didn't just want to
monarchy an executive they said
no we can't do that because here's what
the problem with the executive monarch
you know
autocracy is okay well what about like
direct representation ah no it's too
slow it can't
all right well what about like a council
of elders of learn it no because then
they how about all three of them
they all challenge and check each other
checks and balances separation of powers
co-equal branches
so they took you know montesquieu spirit
of the laws
they read it they studied it they
understood it and they perfected it
but guess what we don't teach spirit of
the laws
in schools what's that montesquiou
that's how we came up with the uh
three branches of government charles
montesquieu that's brilliant have you
heard of the national initiative
mike revell was pushing it senator from
alaska okay and uh it proposes a fourth
branch of government
that would be each state would elect
someone to represent them
and these 50 people could come together
and write laws and pass them into
congress to this
that's the senate but we already have
this we have one it's the
representatives but they're essentially
a monopoly on law making so it would
give people also another opportunity but
you still already have it you know what
you have
in the article 5 convention of states
that's right i'm telling you these guys
sat down and they
thought of every single thing and so
it is not just we have representation
based upon population
we have equal representation based upon
a state
so you have that with the senate but
then also the states have the ability to
have
impact upon the constitution by way of
article five so it's there so
let's build a website where we could get
all these legislations to come together
seamlessly like a social network for
state legislations
for state legislation or u.s legislation
i think for state legislation so that we
could call a constitutional uh
that that that might be difficult
because you got 50 different states but
i think that each and every show that
you all have
you should do just a quick little 10
minute review of some piece of
legislation that has come out
of washington dc hr1 hr5 hr8 you know
127 130 whatever just pick one
and just kind of have a little tutorial
and how would it
affect the states we got to read some
more yeah we do all right crackbot says
tim i've spent over 10 years deploying
in and out of it out of afghanistan
in the military especially in combat
environment even remfs
were being engaged in fighting we had
nurses having to pick up rifles and
fight
you can't lower the standards everyone
is there to fight
and point rem stands for rear echelon
mofos okay that's what that's what it
means and you're right what
what afghanistan and iraq what they are
there
that's asymmetrical warfare uh there is
no front line
and you know then the rear area i mean
the enemy attacks you everywhere
and so every single person that because
you're saying well can we just take them
out and put them in some different
position
every single person has to be ready to
fight that's one thing that
i truly love about the marine corps
because the marine will tell you that
every marine is a rifleman
that's the mentality first i don't care
if you're special there's a lawyer
you're a rifleman
all right we got one that uh is an
important question from dustin wood he
says tim
always admired colonel colonel west i'm
a member of the log cabinet republicans
of texas
we were denied being admitted as a
member of the texas gop last year
can colonel west say why he doesn't
support gay conservative groups joining
i didn't say that i don't support gay
conservative groups jordan that happened
before i came on as the as the chairman
i came on as the chairman of july 2020.
i think the issue is that we have
platforms
that talk about traditional marriage and
we want to make sure that any group
associated with the republican party
texas
supports the platforms of the republican
party of texas because if you don't
support the platforms then you're
undermining
what the republican party of texas
stands for
all right diego rivera says the texas
state gop
party platform uh stars stars
that a declaration of war from congress
uh states maybe
the declaration of war from congress is
required before texas national guardsmen
can be deployed to overseas combat
i agree and 31 states have introduced
defend the guard legislation
chairman west do you agree i agree that
we have to defend our guard and
one of the things that's uh title 10 if
i'm correct
when you activate the guard to go and
serve in an active duty as a matter of
fact
you had a lot of guardsmen that were
serving in operation does shield their
storm now what i am concerned about
is the abuse of our guard and what we
see happening in washington d.c right
now
uh the fact that we cannot put a border
on our southern border with mexico but
yet we have fence and razor wire around
the united states capital
and the national guard patrolling and
standing and manning that
as well as making them sleep in you know
parking garages and eat you know
uncooked food and things of this nature
so i am really concerned about the abuse
of our national guard by this bite
administration
yeah me too man all right this one's
going to be hard for me but i'll try my
best vince r says
former 13b here 13 bravo that's
artillerman
would like to know if colonel west and i
may have crossed paths it says a3
11fa luis 8789
go devil's brigade 77 fa ca knox 8991
a15fa kc 9192
and hsb 320 fa campbell 9294 boy
let me he put a lot of you know
different duty assignments out there let
me just try to encapsulate it and
my first duty of state station was 1984
to 1987 in
vicenza italy with the airborne
battalion there i came back went to fort
sill for advanced artillery school then
i served in four
first infantry division at fort riley
from 88 to 91
got back from desert seal desert storm
met my wife married her she was a
professor at kansas state university
taught army rotc at kansas state from 91
to 95
went to korea second infantry division
95 96
97 the army commander general staff
college
97 to 99 fort bragg north carolina 99 to
2002
second marine expeditionary force 2002
to 2004
4th infantry division for hood texas
thank
you hopefully that answered the question
so he you got to triangulate and figure
out if we ever served together
all right let's see leor engelstein says
as an individual with an ffl
07 and an sot-02 manufacturer of nfa
items
my atf agent's biggest complaint are nfa
items
they want to get rid of the category
because it's too much of a headache for
something that should be an
niscs check all right
johnny smoke says did you guy catch the
video of tim c from rage against the
machine
his belief the u.s is a military coup
and mark millie
and the former chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff hold a higher power than
the president
is that no i don't know anything about
that no that seems a bit
yeah i've been out of there but if they
did would they admit it
you're never going to have a military
coup in the united states of america
isn't the united states is a military
coup
yeah sure wheels says colonel west for
colonel west for president
i'll stop 1979 army 82 a b reporting for
duty sir
well god bless you army strong pj says
lieutenant colonel west
desert storm m1a1 tanker here you're
welcome
thank you man you guys are on the way
right on
jerome morrow says dude you better
record the hell out of tonight's episode
because i want to re-listen to it
colonel west is talking about a lot of
things i want to actively pursue well we
do record it
and it'll be up on itunes spotify and
all those other podcast platforms as
well as youtube plus
we're going to put up segments from the
show tomorrow and we're going to have a
members only exclusive segment coming up
at timecast.com
about an hour from now or so so we'll
just read a few more super chats
and we'll move on there sonny james says
colonel i need your opinion
recently orthodox jews protested a law
that would remove their exemption from
the draft in israel
many western countries doing this what's
your opinion
we are in the early infowars stage of
world war iii as a decorated military
man
let me tell you uh i know that that's
one of the things i think the uh
hasidic and heridi jews over there don't
have to serve but
who would not want to serve their
country especially in a country like
israel that's surrounded by enemies that
want to
destroy you one of the most emotional
things i got to do
on my trips to israel was to go up to
masada
and masada was incredible because those
jewish rebels
instead of surrendering to the romans
and being taken captives and returned
back to slavery
they took their lives wow what a
powerful statement
to say that we would rather live free or
die
rather die on my feet than live on my
knees absolutely and so i would say that
to everyone that is there in israel when
you look
at what is happening in iran when you
look at
syria when you look at lebanon i would
think that every single
able-bodied person would want to be able
to stand on the ramparts of freedom
and honor the memory of the people of
masada because that's what freedom
really means
i think we need more courage from a lot
of people
we do yeah we do and and
when you talked about the people that
instead of
continuing to fight against the social
justice warriors they want to acquiesce
and appease it
all you're doing is you're just
surrendering you're going to be on your
knees
and you're you know you don't want to to
live that life
um i had a general by the name of rick
lynch he was our assistant division
commander when i was in the fourth
infantry division
and he said life is all about how you
live your dash
and the thing that you have to come to
understand is that when you pass away
from this life
on your final resting spot you gotta
start dating you gotta end date
and then between a simple little line a
dash
and everything about your life has to
speak
in that little thing called a dash and
so i would just say what do you want to
be remind
remember it as a person that got on
their knees and surrendered
or a person that stood and fought right
on on that note
that's an excellent note to end off on
check out timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have another segment coming
up in about an hour exclusive for
members only
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast we are live monday
through friday at 8pm and if you're
listening on itunes spotify or any of
these podcast platforms leave us a good
review it really does help
my other youtube channels youtube.com
timcast youtube.comcastnews
don't forget to like share and subscribe
this show
right now and uh most importantly
sharing it
really does help it's the best way to
get the word out on podcast and it's
something we really appreciate
and uh before we go colonel west is
there anything you want to promote or
shout out you got a social media account
or anything
well i do uh you can follow us at the
republican party of texas you can follow
the website facebook twitter
instagram and everything then also my
personal page which is allen west texas
facebook instagram youtube the whole
nine yards twitter
so uh again it's just a pleasure now to
be here with you all thanks so much ian
thanks so much tim thank you so much
madame producer
lydia yes you guys can also follow me in
crossland.net
for all your joy and love alan i love
you man thanks for coming you're too
cool
and you know what the funny thing was i
walked in here in the beginning he's
like
uh who are you
i will that's the best baby yeah well
but that was that that's kind of it like
you know he immediately had 5
000 questions for you yeah and i was
like we got to save it save it
i want to know you not your legacy you
tell me
well but my legacy is me yeah i miss
what i leave
when i leave but we're gonna we're gonna
i think we're we're gonna talk about a
lot about military stuff too yeah you
know
in the next segment so uh don't forget
we got sarpatch also me in the corner
and i want to thank uh colonel
lieutenant colonel west for joining us
fantastic conversation really fun to
drive with him i love driving my guests
from the airport
you can follow me on twitter at real
sour patch lids also on
vines and then on gab and instagram at
real sour bachelorettes
we're gonna go talk about probably
military stuff conflict
over at timcast.com so sign up and we
will see you all then
you